bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre ce
matin l'audition de pierre moscovici
devant le parlement européen
l'ancien patron de bercy a été désigné
pour le poste de commissaire aux
affaires économiques
un poste qui doit encore être confirmée
par un ultime vote et vous allez voir ce
vote n'est pas acquis
l'ancien ministre a dû faire face lors
de cette audition a qu à une franche
hostilité de la droite une droite
sceptique sur sa capacité à juger avec
neutralité l'état des finances française
à l'exception des socialistes
aucun groupe n'a soutenu sa candidature
pierre moscovici dans le collimateur de
la droite notamment allemandes et
françaises
ouais pour avoir été le ministre des
finances d'un pays qu'ils jugent
incapables de réduire ses déficits
publics
alors vous allez le voir lors de cette
audition puis à moscou russie a promis
qu'il ne serait ni l'avocat ni le
procureur de la france tout de suite on
les écoute
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
c'est toujours un plaisir pour moi de
retrouver ce parlement où j'ai siégé de
reprise ces vingt dernières années
un parlement dont je connais et salue le
rôle politique essentielle je me prépare
pour les fonctions de commissaire aux
affaires économiques et financières mais
aussi à la fiscalité à l'union douanière
dans la commission de jean claude
juncker je le fais avec la fierté de
quelqu'un qui s'apprête à servir
totalement l'intérêt général européen
je me suis préparé avec humilité et
surtout avec le sentiment d'une
responsabilité immense face aux défis
politiques et économiques que nous
européens nous devons relever
j'ai une conviction politique profonde
nous sommes l'europe de la dernière
chance
cette conviction gelé forgé au fil d'une
expérience où les affaires européennes
ont toujours tenu le premier plan j'ai
été député européen vice-président de
votre parlement ministre des affaires
européennes vice président de la
commission pour les affaires européennes
de l'assemblée nationale française
enfin ces deux dernières années ministre
de l'économie et des finances de la
france par toute mon histoire par toutes
mes fibres
je suis profondément européen l'europe à
mes yeux
permettez-moi de le dire c'est la grande
épopée politique de notre siècle
je crois fondamentalement que nos
différences nous enrichissent que le
rapprochement des peuples est un bien en
soi que nous sommes plus forts quand
nous parlons d'une seule voix
je la conviction que l'idée européenne
nous a permis de mettre derrière nous le
passé tragique de ce continent en ce
moment même nous célébrons avec émotion
partout en europe
le centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale et les soixante dix ans du
début de la libération de la barbarie
nazie
ça nous rappelle une chose essentielle
qui est que l'europe est née pour sortir
du chaos
et d'ailleurs ce chaos est encore
aujourd'hui à nos portes
j'ai des racines polonaises par ma mère
roumaine pas mon père je viens d'une
famille qui a vécu les errances du monde
d'hier dont parlait stefan zweig et qui
a connu la tragédie insondable de la
shoah je suis convaincu que la
réunification de notre continent en 2004
puis en 2007 auquel j'ai contribué comme
rapporteur pour l'adhésion de la
roumanie le pays où est né mon père
c'est un moment historique pour la
civilisation européenne
en clair être acteurs du projet européen
hier comme aujourd'hui aujourd'hui comme
demain ça pour moi un sens politique
profond et si vous me permettez de la
joute et ça a un sens personnel très
profond en même temps je sais que de
moins en moins de nos concitoyens
partagent cette vision il faut le
reconnaître
l'europe n'est plus une évidence pour
tous beaucoup de citoyens aujourd'hui
sont déçus d'abord parce qu'ils pensent
que l'europe n'a pas su les protéger et
engendrer les progrès nécessaires
ce rejet de l'europe ce sentiment d'une
puissance économique et l'inefficacité
politique je les vois comme est lui
monté depuis des années notamment dans
les milieux populaires et aussi chez les
ouvriers et je ne me résigne pas
mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous ne pouvons pas demander à nos
concitoyens à la jeunesse européenne de
faire encore preuve de patience ou
citoyens frappés par la crise économique
jeunes plus âgés femmes hommes dans tous
nos pays nous ne pouvons plus simplement
répondre par la célébration de la paix
et de la réconciliation entre les
ennemis d'hier qui sont devenus des amis
indissoluble par l'europe
aujourd'hui ce qu'on attend de nous
c'est autre chose ce sont des résultats
et je veux y contribuer pleinement avec
votre soutien
évidemment vont être du côté de l'espoir
du côté de la volonté politique
c'est mon message aujourd'hui et ça va
le rester durant tout moment d'al com
l'europe a engorgé et des avancées ces
dernières années je me souviens de
l'émotion ressentie dans l'hémicycle de
ce parlement européen le jour de
l'élargissement en 2004 je me souviens
plus près de nous de longues nuits à
l'eurogroupe ou un ecofin
ces deux dernières années alors il y
avait un vrai doute existentiel qui
planait sur l'euro et on se retrouvait
toutes les semaines pour éviter l'
éclatement de la zone euro la faillite
des banques avec l'aide précieuse je
dirais même crucial de la banque
centrale européenne aujourd'hui les
spéculations sur l'éclatement la zone
euro ont cessé les pays sous programme
ont consenti des sacrifices douloureux
pour leur peuple et il se redresse
l'union bancaire est aujourd'hui sur les
rails et elle va assurer à terme une
meilleure stabilité financière à
l'europe les déficits publics dans
l'union se sont réduits la zone euro
continue de 7 ans ces dernières années
j'ai participé à tous ses combats et
l'europe est un passionné que je suis en
est fier en même temps il faut avoir la
modestie de reconnaître que si la
stabilité financière et budgétaire est
un impératif absolu
nous sommes avant tout attendu par nos
concitoyens sur le progrès social sur la
croissance sur l'emploi
nous avons un défi qui est de conjurer
la menace du déclin économique de notre
continent et pour ça nous devons nous
battre tous ensemble c'est comme ça que
je conçois ma responsabilité c'est comme
ça que je conçois mon travail avec vous
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je suis heureux aujourd'hui de me mettre
totalement au service de l'intérêt
général européen de travailler dans la
commission européenne qui est pour moi
le véritable coeur avec le parlement de
la méthode communautaire et je me sens
prêt cet engagement je l' ai discuté
avec le président ukr dès le lendemain
des élections européennes
je me réjouis d'entrer dans son équipe
j'ai la volonté d'y travailler en
parfaite coopération avec mes collègues
vice président et commissaire parce que
il faudra l'intelligence de tous
la détermination de chacun
pour sortir l'europe de sa crise
actuelle je suis totalement disponible
pour y contribuer à ma juste place dans
l'esprit de collégialité qui fait la
force unique de la commission je connais
bien le rôle de cette institution et des
commissaires je veux d'ailleurs salué
l'excellente coopération que j'ai eu
comme ministre avec mes deux
prédécesseurs
olli rehn et algirdas semeta ainsi
qu'avec michel barnier dans la genèse de
l'union bancaire la mise et messieurs
les députés nous avons devant nous
beaucoup de chantiers et je veux les
conduire avec votre soutien avec
l'exigence politique démocratique du
parlement que je connais notre feuille
de route commune parce que nous allons
travailler ensemble pour les cinq
prochaines années elle est exigeante
il s'agit de remettre l'économie
européenne en marche au service des
citoyens au service des entreprises et
pour ça nous avons besoin d'un cadre
clair je mettrai toute mon énergie dans
le double combat décisif que nous avons
amené du nhb à préserver la stabilité
notre économie et d'autre part relancer
la croissance
il faut cesser d'opposer ces deux
principes cardinaux
il faut dépasser les clivages inutiles
les critiques politicienne
les attaques personnelles nous le savons
tous il n'y a pas de croissance sans
réduction des déficits et des dettes
publiques et privées mais il n'y a pas
de stabilité et pas de désendettement
sans croissance et donc il faut les deux
à la fois je m'engage donc devant vous à
faire respecter nos règles budgétaires
par tous les états membres
il faut le faire sans complaisance pour
les uns sans excès de dureté pour les
autres il faut traiter tous les états
grands ou petits
selon les mêmes règles et selon leurs
mérites propres
vous pouvez compter sur moi pour être un
arbitre juste et impartiale pour assurer
que tous quel qu'il soit je redis bien
quel qu'il soit joue selon nos règles
communes et fasse progresser nos
économies il parle à rennes
bouteflika policy mix est développée au
niveau des freins abs semestre de rue
viger 90.3 stratégie de jean claude
juncker une descente guy vaste et
opportunity to disk as 10 et sancho
questions ayant committee douce france
finning 10 euros et à des fins bois des
pins est toujours politique qui espionné
in schools and russia invest et takumi
bâtit rien à tous un point des
red wings continue douce au side by side
with valdis dombrovskis cause à believe
pour paris oui livres pour enfants lui
comme en corée il faut l'écrire
kelly committed to you here today to
rock doui l'ange rohff we can't we
should not accept our growth scénario
phonak steve 1-6 6-3 6-2 financial
crisis to respond to be you i still
seventeen de saint cloud dans tout ça
donne aussi le work together with
michael ickx ford blanche aux fruits
andreu belliot nine des semis plane
sanaa aussi par jean claude juncker
europe
gently beau public and private to cry
new businesses in your job tous criaient
d'une fastueuse we need for future
recommencé à lancer et kitana et
jonathan a au scoop de reach of wall
swing rite social justice pas assez d
une mini trip et dames et jim dunn
panini comics crisis d'ascq où tout
marche sauf ring for men and women cross
a continué qui reviennent we can't we
should not accept en prenant les vols
reaching il est venu en tout 110 rue
arias
picking at what if we don't rise and
fall yang pipeau économique gros need to
be sustainable it needs to generate job
to go to guy comme feedback thuyone
people in europe on dispose marianne
thyssen a very similar hazebrouck avec
away with me mais ce niveau social
justice pour fairness and also has high
tech my responsibilities taxation police
invis herria avoir précieux de fight
games tax haven tax haven agressive taxe
plein 600 chevaux rasoir économique et
sécurisé
we have fun and to back sicre signorini
tout content you wrong side des souhaits
addis abeba dj twenty dits automatiques
exchange avait une formation musicale de
new york
le standard a de graves aux lèvres
duquel quand on m'a supporter une
déchéance bateau avec solène maille se
portent tout dit et l'événement the
states that have decided to create et
financial transaction tax and
cooperation à supporter administre six
initiatives durables ni chili est la
vôtre continue to do so à ce mot veut
dire aucune commission elles la 19e get
back kastens policy which is up and very
comme queen questions de protection
c'était alors s est mise un disque lobo
le nouveau need to work together to put
in place des unions newcastle
good bye my two thousand sixtine de six
coups fantasques work closely with a
number of ink aux attaques métis voilà
quelques-uns des chantiers que je me
prépare à conduire avec votre soutien
jean claude juncker a souhaité une
commission qui soit plus efficace plus
politique plus cohérente et au sein de
cette commission
je veux être le garant de l'intérêt
européen
je dirais même de l'intérêt économique
le gardien scrupuleux de nos règles
communes le promoteur d'initiatives
collectives qui vont relancer la
croissance et l'emploi
je connais pour avoir rencontré beaucoup
d'autres vous les questions de certains
je suis français je suis social
démocrate
comment le nier je n'en rougis pas mais
je veux vous dire très directement et de
manière formelle que je ne serai pas
dans mes fonctions
l'ambassadeur d'un pays où d'un parti je
serai comme vous êtes en droit de
l'exiger
un commissaire européen entièrement voué
à sa tâche agissant avec impartialité et
indépendance à l'égard de tous les
intérêts privés ou nationaux à vos côtés
je veux servir la cause européenne
j'ai dit que nous étions l'europe de la
dernière chance je le crois très
profondément
l'europe c'est un magnifique projet
politique mais comme tous les projets
politiques
elle est faillible et si nous n'y
prenons garde les mortels j'ai pour elle
au portefeuille que je serai amené
occuper une ambition une direction et
dans ce contexte je serai disponible
pour travailler étroitement avec le
parlement avec vous avec vous tous dans
tous vos groupes en comptant sur le
concours essentiel des deux directions
générales
placé sous mon autorité je le ferai
qu'une capacité d'écouté de dialogue
renforcé par le respect que j'ai pour
cette assemblée que je connais bien où
j'étais si fier et si heureux de siéger
j'ai aujourd'hui en présentant devant
une longue expérience politique
parlementaire européen parlementaires
nationales ministre je sais à quel point
la responsabilité démocratique est
essentiel que nos institutions et ce
sera pour moi le travail et que vous un
principe d'action absolument primordiale
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés je voulais être un
commissaire responsable et soucieux de
cet engagement démocratique
je sollicite aujourd'hui votre soutien
votre confiance pour relever les défis
qui nous attendent c'est dans cet esprit
avec la volonté de répondre franchement
à vos questions quelle qu'elle soit que
j'aborde cette audition au mercy
merci j'ai dans la parole des orateurs
de groupes de pépé alain lamassoure jeu
commissaires désignés votre candidature
suscite un malaise largement partagé
dans cette assemblée personne de bonne
foi ne peut contester votre expérience
vos qualités votre engagement européen
requis pour la fonction de commissaire
mais personne de bonne foi ne peut
comprendre que le portefeuille auquel
vous prétendez soit celui où vous avez
échoué dans votre pays en charge du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
cet échec ce n'est pas l'opposant
politique que je suis actuellement qui
en juge
c'est le président de la république
française qu'il y a 6 mois a dû changer
de gouvernement
et vous à retirer vos fonctions
précisément parce que la france était
incapable d'honorer ses engagements
européens
d'où la question de quelle crédibilité
pensez vous disposer vis-à-vis de votre
successeur à paris qui demande
aujourd'hui un nouveau report d'échéance
pour respecter les mêmes engagements et
de quelle crédibilité pour et vous
disposez pour juger de la politique et
pour faire des recommandations à ceux de
vos anciens collègues qui ont eu le
courage de faire chez eux les efforts
gigantesques que l'europe attend
toujours de la france merci merci
monsieur lamassoure
je les dis en commençant je suis
français
et je suis fier de l'être mes parents se
sont assez battu pour le devenir
mais en entrant ici je veux agir en
européen avant tout et le rôle du
commissaire européen chargé des affaires
économiques et financières
c'est de défendre les règles toutes les
règles de le faire de manière totalement
crédible alors je ne veux pas esquivé
votre question il ya un aspect pour le
passé et un pour le futur seul sur le
passé c'est sur mon action
vous ne savez peut-être pas pourquoi
j'ai quitté le gouvernement il ya six
mois exactement jour pour jour moi je le
sais et ce ne sont pas pour les raisons
que vous avez dit mais j'ai réduit les
déficits en france quand je suis arrivé
au ministère des finances le déficit
était supérieure à 5%
il filait vers 5 5% j'ai présenté trois
lois de finances rectificatives de loi
de finances et de 5 25% des déficits
sont passés à 4,1 pour cent
fin 2013 dernier but sept budgets dont
j'ai eu la responsabilité et cela s'est
fait au prix d'un effort structurel qui
a été de 0,9 point en 2011
c'était le pré sente vraiment 1,2 en
2012 1,3 en 2013 1,3 tous ces budgets
ont été validés par la commission et en
prévision est en exécution
donc moi je suis quelqu'un qui veut le
sérieux budgétaire qui veut la réduction
des déficits alors la question pour le
futur que ferait face à la situation de
mon pays d'origine
eh bien je lui ai dit j'aurais une
boussole très clair très simple les
règles
rien que les règles toutes les règles je
suis là pour assurer la crédibilité de
notre projet de surveillance budgétaire
c'est ça la mission et aucune autre et
si un pays je les dis quel qu'ils soient
grands ou petits
quel que soit son statut supposé ne
remplit pas les obligations qu'ils sont
prévues par les traités ne prend pas les
actions effectives comme on dit
nécessaires et à ce moment là se trouve
dans une procédure et c'est le cas de la
france je poursuivrai cette procédure
sans faillir c'est ma tâche d'européens
et de commissaires européens c'est celle
qui m'a tour
je veux d'abord dire une chose c'est que
je suis très attaché à l'euro et je suis
très attaché à la destinée de l'euro je
le suis depuis toujours dans mes voc
dans des actions et dans mon rôle de
responsable politique
en même temps nous savons que cette
union économique et monétaire c'est un
grand succès mais qu'elle connaît des
limites et la première de ses limites
en effet c'est con à accorder toute
l'attention au volet monétaire pas
suffisamment volet budgétaire puis au
volet politique
alors nous nous sommes efforcés c'est ce
à quoi servent le tupac elle six pack de
corriger en partie les choses mais nous
savons qu'il faut aller plus loin et de
ce point de vue là il ya le rapport des
quatre présidents
plus encore le blueprint de la
commission 2012 que vous avez cités qui
pose des bases et dans la suite des
lignes directrices poser ici par jean
cocker je vois plusieurs grands
chantiers pour renforcer notre monnaie
unique un il faut renforcer son
architecture institutionnelle et
politique et notamment réfléchir au rôle
et au fonctionnement de l'eurogroupe à
la place du parlement pour assurer une
plus grande responsabilité démocratique
des choix qui sont faits en respectant
l'indépendance de la banque centrale
deuxièmement je le redis devons revoir
nos règles notre pacte commun notamment
les mécanismes créés par le six pack
elle tout pas qu'on a lancé le président
élu comme prévu par la législation et là
encore votre parlement a son mot à dire
il faudra troisièmement renforcer la
dimension sociale de la zone euro et
assurer une convergence qui ne soit pas
que monétaire et qui ne se traduisent
pas vers une fuite vers le bas enfin il
faut poursuivre l'élargissement de la
zone euro et je lui dise c'est une
préparation active et un jugement
objectif qui devra présider aux
éventuels prochain élargissement de la
zone euro tout cela en revoyant la
gouvernance de cette zone euro
comme ministre j'ai eu l'occasion
d'émettre des avis personnel je continue
de les partager
en même temps c'est au conseil européen
c'est au conseil et au parlement de
travailler ensemble sur ces sujets
besoin d'une union économique et
monétaire complète ambitieuse politique
sociale monétaire
budgétaire c'est à ça que je veux
travailler avec vous que je pense en
effet que revoir le six pack et le tupac
est un travail qui est entrepris en ce
moment avec un rendez vous qui se tient
à la fin de cette année 2014 et dans
lequel votre parlement européen devra
être écoutés il y assez vrai scoreboard
il faudra examiner point par point vous
comprendrez que je ne peux pas le faire
aujourd'hui ce que sont les indicateurs
qui doivent être renforcés conserver
peut-être changer en même temps soyons
clair ce que nous voulons faire c'est
davantage soutenir défend simplifier que
de modifier les règles qui sont les
nôtres et nous devons assurer qu'il y à
davantage de cohésion économique
davantage de cohésion sociale dans la
poursuite des travaux que nous menons
ensemble
à cet égard les réflexions du parlement
ne seront extrêmement précieuse dans les
travaux que j'aurais a conduit jeu
je voulais dit madame je suis venu ici
avec humilité donc je ne vais pas dire
que je suis le meilleur pour ceci ou
pour cela je ne veux me garder de toute
forme d'arrogance ou d'excès de
certitudes
en même temps j'ai été choisi pour
exercer cette responsabilité par le
président élu jean claude juncker et
c'est donc moi qui suis ici pour ce
faire
je ne vais pas travailler seuls je les
dis je travaille dans la collégialité
le président a souhaité une nouvelle
architecture de la commission il ya un
pack économique
il ya notamment deux vice présidents
yves kiehl catane est née valdis
dombrovskis c'est avec lesquels je veux
travailler étroitement et je n'oublie
pas les autres commissaires que j'ai
mentionné jonathan lynn marianne thyssen
nous sommes une équipe
alors pour le reste je suis convaincu en
effet qu'il faut renforcer la
compétitivité de nos économies
vous évoquez ce que j'ai pu faire
track-record comme vous dites
pendant les deux années où j'étais au
mystère l'économie des finances devons
réformer le marché du travail nous avons
réformé la formation professionnelle
nous avons fait en sorte favoriser
l'investissement des entreprises à
travers un pacte de responsabilité de 40
milliards il y à des réformes
économiques qui sont entreprises avons
payé et vous savez d'autres pays
engager de telles réformes ça prend du
temps l'allemagne je n'ai pas à me
prononcer sur ce qui a pu faire gerhard
schröder jadis il a fallu dix ans pour
que l'allemagne qu'on disait à l'époque
l'homme malade de l'europe quand je t'ai
mis des affaires européennes deviennent
l'économie la plus forte il faut du
temps aussi pour la france
mais mon rôle encore une fois n'est pas
d'être ici le musée comme il est de la
france
je ne suis plus là je suis un européen
je suis quelqu'un qui croit au sérieux
dans la gestion des finances publiques
je suis quelqu'un qui croit à l'effort
juste quelqu'un qui croit aux réformes
je suis quelqu'un qui suis persuadé que
c'est par la compétitivité des
entreprises que nos économies
grandissent et c'est à ceux là je vais
me consacrer je les dis à ma place à ma
juste place
seulement ma place mais toute ma place
le meilleur ou pas c'est à vous d'en
juger
en tout cas je me sens prêt à exercer
ses responsabilités à la fois par tout
ce que j'ai fait par tout ce que je
pense et par tout ce que je propose dans
les lignes de jean claude juncker
jumelles à mathias j'ai dit dans mon
propos addictif je pense que nous devons
agir simultanément sur la consolidation
budgétaire comme on dit sur la réduction
des déficits et sur la croissance car en
vérité il n'y a pas de réduction des
déficits sans croissance il n'y a pas de
croissance sans désendettement je suis
convaincu depuis toujours que
l'endettement est une dépense totalement
improductive le service de la dette
comme on dit chaque euro qui lui
consacrait c'est un euro en moins pour
l'éducation pour l'hôpital pour le
service public 100 euros perdus pour
l'économie et donc il faut des endettés
nos économies mais en même temps il faut
le faire grâce à la croissance et créer
un cercle vertueux
alors dans ce contexte là je veux être
extrêmement clair commissaire chargé des
affaires économiques et financières
je serai je lui dit le gardien des
règles le garant de l'intérêt économique
de l'europe
je ne vais pas ici prétend ce serait un
mensonge que je suis là pour l'échangé
je suis là pour les appliquer avec en
même temps les marges qu'elle offre on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler
dans cette audition en même temps ce qui
est clair c'est que le cas que vous
donnez jean claude juncker et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec lui à cette
commission
c'est un quatre tournées vers la
croissance
c'est un cap qui est tourné vers
l'investissement c'est un cap qui prend
mieux en compte les souffrances sociales
sur le continent c'est un cap qui donne
la priorité à la lutte contre le chômage
et notamment contre le chômage des
jeunes et qui implique que dans toutes
les politiques que nous menons nous
prenions davantage en compte cette
dimension sociale c'est pour ça que il
est bon qu'il y ait un vice président
monsieur dont bruce lee ce qui est à la
fois soit chargée de la politique de
l'euro mais aussi du dialogue social et
bien moi j'irai dans ce contexte là et
j'attache notamment une très grande
importance aux plans d'investissements à
la fois publiques et privées de 300
milliards d'euros destiné à permettre de
créer ces emplois dont nous avons besoin
ces investissements nous avons besoin de
renforcer la compétitivité de l'économie
européenne
voilà je ne veux pas opposer les deux la
dimension budgétaire et la dimension
économique
nous devons continuer à rayonner déficit
nous devons le faire en ayant toujours
en tête que c'est l'économie réelle
qu'il faut servir pour l'emploi
communiste les commis des finances j'ai
siégé pendant deux ans à l'eurogroupe
ont suivi notamment la situation des
pays sous programme
j'ai siégé au conseil ecofin bien sûr et
je sais à quel point les pays sous
programme les grecs et chypriotes
les irlandais les espagnols ont vraiment
souffert de la crise ont fait des
efforts essentiel pour se redresser
communisme s'est rendu trois fois en
grèce deux fois par mois même une fois
avec le président la république
j'ai milité je me suis battu pour
l'intégrité de la zone euro mais je sais
en même temps qu'il ya eu d'énormes
souffrances que les taux de chômage sont
insupportables et qui a le sentiment
parfois qu'on impose de l'extérieur des
contraintes qui sont douloureusement
vécus par la population
la troïka dans ce contexte notre cas je
considère qu'elle a fait un travail
nécessaire parce qu'elle a permis
d'éviter le défaut dans ces pays elle a
permis l'implantation de réformes dites
structurelles et il faut continuer à
travailler avec fonds monétaire
international je pense que d'abord c'est
prévu dans le tupac ensuite c'est aussi
un élément de réassurance qui est
nécessaire mais il faut sans doute
modifié
cette façon de fonctionner c'est ce qu'a
dit jean claude juncker devant le
parlement européen
il a dit qu'il allait faire des
propositions pour favoriser la
légitimité démocratique pour faire en
sorte que le parlement soit plus associé
qu'on prenne en compte la dimension
sociale qu'on travaille dans le dialogue
social sur toutes ces questions
peut-être aussi qu'on soit moins
intrusif dans un certain nombre de
politiques
alors ça c'est une réforme à laquelle je
travaillerai je pense qu'il ne faut pas
du tout jeter l'opprobre sur la tre k
elle a joué et joue encore un rôle utile
il faut même temps prendre en compte les
attentes des peuples prendre en compte
les attentes sociales modifier les
méthodes
c'est ce que le président élu a dit ici
je peux pas davantage donné de détails
sur ce que nous ferons mais je peux vous
dire vraiment ma volonté de travailler
avec vous est ce que les choses se
modifie de façon très substantielle
je le redis je leur dirai encore je le
redirai jusqu'à la fin de sa position je
leur dirai pendant les cinq ans je serai
commissaire européen
je suis là pour faire respecter les
règles je suis là pour assurer la
crédibilité des règles je ne suis pas là
pour les modifier de façon créative
je ne suis pas là pour défendre une
secte elle dérogation je ne sais quel
exception je ne sais quel suspension
nous avons des règles et ces règles
elles sont là pour être respecté elles
doivent être crédibles elles sont
intelligentes elles ne sont pas stupides
elle examine de façon individuelle la
situation des pays
elles prennent en compte la situation
économique
elle insiste par exemple sur cette
notion très importante
quels efforts structurels mais un pays
quel qu'il soit je le répète
quelle que soit sa taille quel que soit
son histoire quel que soit son statut
supposé un pays fussent la france doit
respecter les règles et mon rôle à moi
c'est de faire respecter ces règles
comme commissaire européen et c'est ce
que je ferai et donc moi je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas le
commissaire en charge
c'est monsieur katainen les éléments au
sujet du projet qui était présenté hier
apparemment ils nécessitent pour moi un
examen approfondi il ya des choses qui
souffrons avec la commission présente
la fin octobre début novembre il y à
d'autres je prendrai en charge dès le
début devant avec les prévisions
économiques de la commission
il faudra prendre des décisions ou en
octobre ou en neuf ans eh bien je les
prendrais injuste je vous redis très
simplement ce que j'ai déjà répondu à
monsieur lamassoure
si un pays dans une procédure déficit
excessif ne prend pas les effectifs
actions prévues par les traités ne fais
pas mes efforts culturel requis ne mène
pas les réformes structurelles exigées
alors à ce moment-là il n'y a pas de
doute il n'y a pas d'hésitation il n'y a
pas de choisir âge il faut poursuivre le
procès dure et le commissaire que je
serai je répète un commissaire européen
et non plus le ministre des finances
français que je ne suis plus depuis six
mois ce commissaire européen fera son
travail et son devoir
oui bonjour monsieur moscovici tout
d'abord merci de nous honorer de votre
présence et bravo d'apparaître sans peur
devant les députés de la commission econ
vraiment le changement c'est maintenant
à vous écouter jusque là le changement
c'est également votre volonté de
respecter au niveau européen la
discipline budgétaire pourtant sans être
cruel avec vous je suis quand même
obligé de vous rappeler que c'est sous
votre ministère que la france a été
placé le 5 mars dernier sous
surveillance renforcée par la commission
européenne pour ses dérapages budget
budgétaire permanent ce n'est donc pas
pour votre bilan à bercy que monsieur le
coeur à désigner mais c'est bien pour le
seul critère d'embauché valable votre
nationalité
le cap des 2000 milliards d'euros de
dette publique a été franchi récemment
soit 30000 euros par français et bientôt
le seuil de 100% du pile sera pas normal
c'est le logiciel ultra libérale de
l'ump s en france qui bug en réalité
pour tout le système il ya urgence que
la france deuxième économie de la zone
euro serait forme qu'à sa banqueroute
financière entend dès la fin de la
monnaie unique
alors vous l'avez dit vous êtes
déterminés à faire vos preuves aussi ma
question est simple monsieur moscovici
vous qui prétendez aimer la france en
votre âme et conscience
lorsque la france ne rentrera pas dans
les critères fixés par brusque par
bruxelles serait vous prêt à déclencher
le feu nucléaire dès la procédure de
discipline budgétaire
pax contre votre patrie et mettre en
esclavage
je n'ai pas bien compris le franchement
monsieur mono si vous me reprochez de ne
pas défendre l'euro que nous semble-t-il
vous défendez peu de mettre en mon pays
d'origine dans l' esclavage ou bien de
ne pas respecter les disciplines il y
avait un peu de confusion
je dois le dire dans votre propos si
vous le permettez il faudra peut-être
que vous même vous clarifier vos propres
options
ça c'est votre problème ce n'est pas le
mien pour le reste je ne peux que redire
ce que j'ai déjà été à venir sa tondeuse
fois je répondrais je les dis à toutes
les questions ne faut pas non plus se
débat entre nous il ya tellement de
sujets dans l'europe pour le débat sur
un seul pays je pense que ça mérite
aussi autre chose
notre échange mais je n'ai pas
d'hésitation je les dis il y à des
règles qui doivent être respectées
le commissaire aux affaires économiques
et financières
il est là pour défendre l'intérêt
économique européen l'intérêt général
européen
les règles européennes je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse assimiler ces règles en
quoi que ce soit un feu nucléaire
il faut avoir un peu de pudeur un peu de
décence par rapport à ceux qui ont été
victimes de l'armé nucléaire
c'est arrivé ou qui sont menacés par sa
non il y a des règles et ces règles
prévoient tout une gradation on peut
modifier des recommandations on peut
accorder des délais c'est arrivé à la
france mais aussi à d'autres pays on
peut aussi déclencher des sanctions
on peut renforcer les mécanismes de
surveillance
ça existe et toute cette palette elle
est à la disposition du commissaire que
je suis mais de la commission toute
entière car ces décisions doivent être
prises collégialement et je ferai en
sorte que cela soit à
donc vous pouvez être tout à fait
tranquille monsieur mono d'abord c'est
bien dans le rôle d'un commissaire
européen que j'entends agir
j'entends le fer avec larmes des règles
n'est pas une arme nucléaire
ménard intelligente et subtile j'entends
le faire avec toute l'intelligence que
précisément ces règles autorise avec
toute la fermeté
quel est il tokyo la corbeille je vous
remercie à présent au nom du groupe ppe
pablo merci si le président est aussi le
commissaire a dézoné soyez le bienvenu
au parlement européen
et cela fait un certain temps déjà que
nous vous attendons en tant que ministre
d'un portefeuille économique mais nous
ne vous en bon j'en ai vu jusqu'à
présent
alors vous dites qu'il faut mettre fin
aux spéculations
mais c'est grâce aux réformes au niveau
européen comme au niveau national c'est
grâce à l'effort déployé par de nombreux
européens sont réalisés ces réformes
est-ce que la spéculation a cessé et
c'est justement cette absence de réforme
qui pèsent sur l'économie européenne des
réformes sont nécessaires dans certains
états membres comme cela peut être le
cas de la france d'où ma question vous
sentez vous légitime pour demander plus
de réformes aux pays qui en ont besoin
deuxième question en tant que
commissaire des humains pensez vous que
votre pays la france à procéder aux
réformes suffisante pour relancer la
croissance et la création d'emplois
allez-vous exiger plus de réformes dans
ce pays je vous remercie
tu les députés me semble que j'ai déjà
commencé pour le moins à répondre à
cette question
d'abord je veux dire à quel point je
suis heureux d'être devant votre
commission j'étais venu
fin 2012 avec mon collègue et ami volga
chat bleu et c'est une commission que je
respecte que je connais j'en ai été
membre jadis liquidités mission très
importante de ces parlements et je vous
redis que je suis à un homme politique
qui a maintenant j'ai pas si c'est
heureux ou malheureux une longue
expérience mon premier mandat ça a été
mon élection comme député européen en
1994 cédé 20 ans et je sais que le
rapport entre un exécutif et un
parlement est décisif je serai bien sûr
à votre disposition pour travailler vous
à votre écoute et je pense que chaque
fois que le parlement a des propositions
importantes intéressantes à faire
entendre il faut non seulement tenir
compte mais les appliquer dans la
réalité pour le reste je réponds une
fois de plus sur la question que vous
m'avez posée au sujet de la france je
suis ici comme commissaire européen
désigné je ne suis plus le ministre de
l'économie et des finances la france je
sais ce que j'ai fait dans ce rôle à la
fois dans la réduction des déficits je
les ai rappelés dans l'application des
règles je peux le rappeler dans la
conduite de certaines réformes
est-ce que ça a été suffisant sans doute
pas car la situation de ce pays est
encore difficile je suis fier de ce que
j'ai fait et j'aurais aimé faire mieux
car il faut de l'humilité dans toutes
les fonctions c'est pas facile d'être
mise de l'économie et des finances d'un
groupe i mon amie louise tekin dos le
sait par exemple nous aurons bien
travailler ensemble y compris quand il
s'est agit de définir un projet un
programme intelligent pour les banques
espagnoles et d'éviter une mise sous
tutelle que j'aurais jugé inacceptable
et mes amis espagnols le sable alors moi
je souhaite continuer dans cet esprit
qu'est l'esprit du sérieux budgétaire
qui est l'esprit de la réforme des
réformes oui au pays est d'origine la
france a besoin de réformes
il les a engagés il reviendra à la
commission d'évaluer si c'est de façon
suffisante si les effectifs action nous
apercevons qu'ils sont exigés ont été
remplies ou pas et je le ferai sans
faiblir
thank you merci au nom de groupe lcp
iacoban weizsacker
moscovici monsieur moscovici
j'aimerais vous poser une question sur
la future architecture de la zone euro
non le passé nous avons surmonté
beaucoup de crises plus ou moins bien
mais une des questions centrales des
années à venir sera de maîtriser les
crises futures et d'être mieux équipée
aussi au plan institutionnel pour
surmonter ses crises futures
alors il ya des propositions de réformes
sur la table en france en allemagne et
dans d'autres pays
des intellectuels ils ont travaillé et
ont fait des propositions mais
j'aimerais savoir quelle est votre
vision pour une meilleure architecture
de la zone euro pour que notre monnaie
commune puisse vraiment être solide et
durable
merci monsieur le député j'ai commencé à
répondre à cette question il ya quelques
minutes
je redis à quel point je suis un
défenseur un partisan j'étais en artisan
aussi de l'euro je crois que cette
monnaie qui est commune
un grand nombre de pays de l'union
européenne que d'autres et tous les
autres en réalité ont vocation à
rejoindre que cette monnaie est un atout
que cette monnaie est un acquis un
acquis précieux
anaky indispensable anaky vital ils
devront tout faire pour conforter leur
euro c'est-à-dire aussi pour améliorer
comme je lé dire ses dimensions sociales
ses dimensions économiques faire en
sorte que cette architecture soit
complète au coeur de tout ça si je
comprends bien les questions il ya aussi
la question de la gouvernance de la zone
euro sur laquelle en effet des
intellectuels des penseurs des
universitaires je pense aux cliniques
groupe je pense à l'effet groupe je
pense à d'autres encore ont commencé à
réfléchir et je me suis exprimé à titre
personnel je suis certain de sujets
exemple faut-il ou pas un président
permanent de leur groupe
ma conviction c'est plutôt oui même s'il
faudra que les décisions soient prises
au niveau approprié
faut-il ou pas que votre parlement
s'organise comme le font par exemple
ministre pour travailler entre pena zone
euro c'est complètement
à vous de le décider faut-il ou pas une
capacité financière de la zone euro
le dessus les présidents juncker a pris
quelques engagements
il s'est déclaré favorable à tout ça moi
sur ces travaux là j'ai bien sûr mes
convictions personnelles
je suis ouvert au dialogue avec vous je
pense que les choses doivent évoluer
assez profondément dans l' architecture
de la zone euro et c'est à nous d'y
travailler ensemble j'y viendrai avec
mes idées mais aussi avec ses volonté
d'écouté de dialogue avec les
intellectuels avec vous que j'évoquais
haouet mais c'est esther d'alain roche
merci je suis parisien péguy nous
l'avons compris mais soyons un peu plus
clair alors le gouvernement français
annoncé unités ralement et hier qu'il
n'allait même pas essayer de réduire son
déficit budgétaire donc ma première
question est ce que c'est aux français
de décider où est ce que c'est à la
commission européenne vu la position de
la france deuxièmement les règles
déclare clairement qu aucun délai n'est
possible pour les pays qui ne tente même
pas de se remettre sur le droit chemin
et puis deuxième question est ce que
vous allez exprimé un non clair au plan
français annoncé hier oui ou non vous
pouvez répondre par oui ou non
troisièmement le gouvernement français a
annoncé qu' il n'y aurait aucun autre
réforme exigée des français et ça c'est
ma plus grande peur qu passion comment
allez vous expliquer aux grecs aux
portugais aux irlandais et même aux
néerlandais
comment allez vous leur expliquez que
eux ont dû prendre des mesures
et que les français eux par contre ne
vont pas devoir le faire est ce que vous
serez un commissaire de la ferme des
animaux où certains sont plus égaux que
d'autres serez vous un commissaire
équitable merci ça c'est des films
inégaux
madame de langue comme je le dis il ya
quelques instants pour le moment je ne
suis pas en charge de ce portefeuille
un collègue mon futur prédécesseur mon
ami 4 monsieur katainen est en charge de
ce dossier mais je peux vous répondre
avec les principes clairs le premier
c'est que c'est à la commission
européenne et pas un gouvernement qu'il
revient de décider si un délai doit être
obtenue la france a obtenu un délai
j'étais ministre des finances et ce
délai l'état corner en respectant les
règles et avec décision de mon collègue
et ami olli rehn
c'est donc à la commission qu'il revient
de prendre une décision et pas un
gouvernement de prendre une décision
unilatérale
deuxièmement alors je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en est je ne peux
pas juger du budget présenté hier je ne
dispose pas des éléments nécessaires
mais je serai en solidarité totale et
complète avec ce que décide la
commission barroso pour le moment et
j'examinerai ce budget lorsque
j'entrerai en fonction en y appliquant
les principes que j'ai évoqués et en
respectant les règles avec une
crédibilité totale
troisièmement comme je les dis mon pays
d'origine et j'en suis fier c'est la
france je resterai français je suis
profondément français
je suis tellement français finalement à
bien des égards mais ici je serai là
comme commissaire européen et cela
signifie qu'il ya un principe essentiel
le traitement égal il ne serait
absolument pas acceptable d'octroyer des
privilèges un pays alors que d'autres et
des citoyens d'autres pays on
réaliser des efforts j'agis je devrais
donc avec équité et en respectant le
principe de traitement équitable je peux
le répéter dix fois si vous voulez vous
pouvez en être certains je suis là pour
garantir la crédibilité du pacte pas
pour le menacer
je ne serai oui pas du tout indulgent je
ne souhaite pas ruiner la crédibilité du
pacte le ma crédibilité et celle de la
commission donc j'agirai dès que j'en
ferai en fonction des preuves
merci pervenche berès groupe s&d merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
commissaire désigné lors du conseil
européen du 26 et 27 juin dernier les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ont
donné mandat à la commission de préparer
un document pour faire le meilleur usage
possible de la flexibilité qui existe
dans les règles du pacte de stabilité
je constate que depuis le début de cette
édition une audition nous parlons
beaucoup des règles en mai les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement nous ont
demandé d'interpréter les flexibilités
qui existe dans ces règles qu'est-ce-qui
de votre point de vue justifie qu'on en
soit venu à cette demande des chefs
d'état de gouvernement et qu'est ce que
vous attendez de ce parlement dans la
feuille de route qui vous a été demandé
de plus je vous rappellerai que ce
parlement lorsqu'il a adopté le 6 pattes
avait avec celui qui est votre
prédécesseur avant monsieur katainen
monsieur les rênes défini un certain
nombre d'idées de pistes en matière
d'investissement de flexibilité pour
l'investissement qui manifestement n'ont
pas donné leurs fruits
comment envisagez-vous cette séquence en
effet j'ai beaucoup parlé le des règles
et je veux dire d'abord ce que la
flexibilité ne peut pas être à mon sens
la flexibilité ce n'est pas le
changement de règle ce n'est pas une
interprétation
kreactive de manière très bons riffs et
c'est quelqu'un qui est peu de cheveux
qui vous le dit des règles je ne suis
pas là pour ça je suis là pour faire en
sorte que ces règles soient respectées
en même temps notre système est un
système intelligent car comme je les dis
il n'est pas président il évalue les
pays individuellement
il prend en compte les circonstances
économiques et ses circonstances peuvent
changer d'ailleurs il y à sa tombe de
clauses qui peuvent être activés
uniquement dans des conditions très
temporaire et dans des circonstances
bien particulières
et troisièmement il prend en compte
l'effort structurel avant tout le
déficit nominaux c'est important mais
c'est l'effort structurel qui prévaut je
rappelais tout à l'heure que quand
j'étais mis des finances l'effort
structurel de la france avait été de 1
2% en 2012 un level 3 % en 2013 c'est ça
qui est tout à fait cardinal alors comme
l'a dit jean claude juncker devant le
parlement
ces flics sibilité là elles ont été
utilisées dans le passé elles peuvent
l'être dans le futur mais avec la même
intelligence et encore une fois toujours
les règles comme un principe de battre
j'ajoute que il y aura des des exercices
que le parlement va être associé de
révision du 6 pas que et de revue du
tupac que cela se passera dans l'année
2014 mais qui serait évidemment très
attentif à tout ce que le parlement
européen aura à dire jean communiqué
indique cet exercice se poursuivraient
en 2015 ou le poursuivront vous pouvez
aller de certaines monnaies mme berès
ensemble étroitement ensemble car comme
je lui dis un toutes les propositions du
parlement européen mérite considération
et beaucoup évidemment vous avez ce
pouvoir applications
20 kg où je vous remercie maintenant
othmar karas
je suis monsieur le commissaire désigné
consentons tout ce que votre principal
problème de crédibilité
c'est la différence entre ce que vous
devez faire et c'est que vous auriez pu
faire dans les relations entre la france
et l'europe
le véritable problème est que les bases
juridiques sont les mêmes et vous auriez
déjà pu faire ce que l'on promettait de
faire je reviens sur vos réponses
écrites dans votre déclaration vous
parlez d'une capacité fiscale dans le
cadre européen s'est orienté vers un
cible vous parlez d'une répartition des
risques
pour renforcer l'union économique et
monétaire comment envisagez-vous cette
répartition des risques et vous ne
voulez pas approfondie l'union
économique et monétaire tant que les
budgets publics ne sont pas stabilisées
mais nous voulons que le patronat se
passe sur des fonctions en suivant des
méthodes communautaire et qu'il y ait
des sanctions sont allez vous prendre
des mesures pour parlementarisme ces
différents éléments vers 6h question de
votre question monsieur égard à ce que
je vous remercie de m'avoir posé je
reviens une fois de plus puisque vous me
donnez sur les différences entre ce que
j'aurais pu faire ce que j'aurais dû
faire et ce que je ferai pour rappeler
simplement un fait qui est un fait
indéniable
et c'est pendant les deux années où
j'étais mais je les connais des finances
de mon pays j'ai fait voter de loi de
finances 2 3 de finances rectificative
ou une loi de programmation des finances
publiques
une loi organique sur les finances
publiques qui a créé un conseil qui est
une instance indépendante qui donnaient
des avis parfois sévère sur ce que fait
le gouvernement et que tout cela s'est
fait tout cela s'est fait en parfait
accord
la commission tout a été approuvée tout
par la commission et en quelle vision et
en exécution
je n'ai jamais dérogé aux règles je ne
m'appelle pas ce que j'ai dit sur le
fait que les déficits ont baissé pendant
cette période là et donc c'est clair je
suis quelqu'un qui croie ou sérieux huit
étages c'est quelqu'un qui croie
oreilles je n'y ai jamais dérogé je ne
le dérangerait pas de l'autre côté comme
un commissaire je n'accepterai pas aux
demandes l'exception suspension des
relations
il ne s'agit comme ça ensuite vous
m'interrogez sur un autre point qui est
moins aussi important qui est
l'approfondissement de l'union on a
commencé à parler tout à l'heure de la
troïka avec monsieur guy gold est à
l'évidence il ya des changements qui
sont à apporter pour que l
approfondissement démocratique de ces
procédures existent et l'association du
parlement européen et l'association des
partenaires sociaux de même vous
m'interrogez implicitement sur la
communautarisation du mécanisme européen
je suis un partisan ardent de la méthode
communautaire et je pense qu'il faut
aller dans ce sens là tout ce qui
permettra d'accroître le rôle du
parlement gmac il rêve de manière
positive
en même temps c'est vrai qu'il faudra
examiner les choses avec attention parce
que comme vous savez il ya beaucoup de
ces progrès qui exigent des changements
de traité et nous sommes dans une
période où les changements de côté pour
des raisons constitutionnelles dans
l'ordre interne certains pays et pour
des raisons aussi démocratiques sont
compliquées mais moi ce sera un partisan
de la méthode communautaire et de
l'approfondissement l'union économique
et monétaire
avec cette arme la merci pour le serbe
en plus que monsieur moscovici
je voudrais vous poser une question sur
la politique fiscale
l'union européenne a émis des
recommandations spécifiques par pays
pour 2013 et constater qu'en france
cette recommandation spécifique sur la
politique
fiscal n'a été mise en oeuvre que
partiellement
alors je voudrais vous demander de me
citer trois recommandations concrètes de
l'union européenne
donc concrètement un deux trois six
témoins trois recommandations de l'union
européenne qui n'ont pas été mises en
oeuvre en france ou qui nous l'ont été
que de façon partielle et je voudrais
vous demander d'expliquer pourquoi sous
votre responsabilité ces recommandations
n'ont pas été mises en oeuvre
dites nous si vous avez estimé que ces
recommandations n'était pas juste c'est
la raison pour laquelle elles n'ont pas
été mises en oeuvre ou bien si vous ne
les avez pas mises en oeuvre parce que
vous n'avez pas été en mesure de le
faire j'aimerais aussi vous vous
demandez avec l autorité en tant que
commissaire vous avez vis-à-vis des
autres pays insisté pour la mise en
oeuvre des recommandations parce qu'on
va vous dire que vous même vous ne les
aviez pas mis en oeuvre chez vous merci
encore une fois je veux répéter je le
répèterai autant qu'il le faudra c'était
ma conviction profonde est ce que j'ai
fait je redis ce que j'ai dit à monsieur
cajas il ya un instant commises et
l'économie des finances
j'ai toujours agi selon les règles il
n'y a pas une décision que j'ai prise en
matière budgétaire qui n'a été validé
par la commission y en a pas une qui
était accepté par le conseil
il n'y aura pas une dont j'ai discuté en
amont avec notamment deux personnes avec
olli rehn commissaire aux affaires
économiques et monétaires avant moi avec
aussi mon ami et collègue wolfgang
schauble mon ami allemand est ce que je
crois très profondément au couple franco
allemand
il n'est pas suffisant pour faire en
sorte que l'europe avance mais si les
français les allemands ne sont pas
d'accord
rien ne se passe dans l'europe et c'est
ainsi que j'ai toujours agi et c'est
ainsi que j'agirais toujours je répète
quand j'étais ministre
pour moi c'était important de respecter
ces règles et ne l'étant plus de marc je
me suis déjà mettant commissaire
européen je serai là moi même pour le
faire appliquer et respecter et vous ne
trouverez pas vous ne trouverez pas un
exemple et qu'ils puissent m'être
reprochée d'exception dérogation
suspension par rapport à ces règles
alors après la france est dans une
procédure
la procédure de déficits publics
excessifs et ces procédures a concerné
jusqu'à 21 pays l'union européenne elle
encore sonne encore aujourd'hui 11
ces procédures et les riches qu'elle
procéderait nous donne tout un arsenal
dont nous pouvons faire usage et je
redis ici que je n'hésiterai en rien à
faire usage de cet arsenal
pour le reste vous allez vous rapportez
vous même parce que la commission a pu
dire sur ce sujet
mais j'ai répondu à vos questions
monsieur devient extrêmement précises je
crois et et qu'est ce que vous voulez me
faire faire je ne vais pas je suis ici
le commissaire européen désigné le
dossier français est examiné par la
commission il est sur des bases
objectives avec les données de la
commission
5 heures merci pts les exports le copain
de messi commissaires désignés et notre
commission dont vous étiez membre dans
le passé vous inviter à lisser les prix
en tant que ministre des finances par ou
expliqué sur les recommandations de la
commission européenne
vous n'avez jamais daigné venir nous
défendre de la situation économique de
votre pays tous les autres ministres ont
une approche proactive
vous insistez pourtant jolie
si l'importance que vous accordez à la
coopération avec le parlement européen
bon je ne dis pas qu'ils aient ces
nouvelles ati tout est ici
mais est-elle définitive cette attitude
de ma part je disais qu'il n'est ni
nouvelle
ni provisoire dure depuis longtemps je
le répète j'ai été élu pour la première
fois dans ce parlement en 1994
je suis revenu en 2004 et j'ai été
vice-président du parlement et je
connais beaucoup d'entre vous
personnellement beaucoup ce qui était de
ces époques là nous avons travaillé
ensemble et je crois bien travailler
ensemble je crois avoir été un vice
président à ma place qui a fait un
travail correct il est toujours
respecter le travail du parlement
le travail du parlement sur la
régulation financière le travail du
parlement sur l'union bancaire et il
nous parlera beaucoup contribué à
infléchir les accords initiaux du
conseil en la matière
le travail du parlement sur le six pack
et sur le tout par le travail du
parlement sur tout ce qui concerne
l'évolution prévisible est souhaitée de
la troïka
alors après vous évoquez c'est vrai ça
tombe mal entendu le concours de
circonstances que je veux adresser ici
vie dont je veux vous dire que je ne
regrette sincèrement
d'abord je suis venue devant votre
commission connais bien c'était avec mon
collègue et ami pour qu'un chômeur
décembre 2012
ensuite il ya eu des rendez vous manqués
que je le redis jean a great le 14
novembre 2013
j'étais pas disponible le 12 et 13
février 2013 14
j'étais aux états unis en visite d'état
du président la république le 17 mars
c'est là où il ya eu un vrai problème
j'ai été invité à une réunion au budget
terre n'est pas très tendu sur la
préparation du thé stable par le
président de la république
j'ai informé les services de la
commission trois jours avant j'ai
demandé que des regrets soit fait au nom
de la commission
cela peut plus être fait encore une fois
je regrettais plus été invités le 17
avril mais là un problème ce n'était
plus ministre n aime pas encore
parlementaire dans les nouvelles
fonctions qui sont les miennes et qui
sont différentes
le commissaire européen je leur dis de
manière définitive de manière ferme de
manière absolue je suis à la disposition
de votre commission et je dirais même de
vos commissions parce que j'accorde à ça
les plus grands importance
bayer merci hugues bayet pour le groupe
a cédé dans une seule commissaire vous
l'avais dit dans votre peau introductif
vous devez tout faire pour soutenir la
croissance et l'emploi et vous mettez
notamment en avant ce grand plan
d'investissement 300 milliards pour
soutenir l'investissement privé public
je voudrais savoir de manière un peu
plus précise ce que vous comptez faire
ce canton regard des investissements
privés on voit que malheureusement le
mécanisme tel terreau ne fonctionne pas
les banques nous disant qui a pas assez
de demandes pour créer de
l'investissement privé et je pose aussi
également beaucoup de questions sur
l'investissement public quand on va la
dette de noces d'état comment allez-vous
pouvoir soutenir nos investissements
publics productif et jeudi introductif
pas dans le seul objectif d'alourdir la
dette mais je pense par exemple à nos
autoroutes a9 zoning industriel nos
plateformes multimodales aux aéroports
aux hôpitaux logements sociaux qui sont
nécessaires je pense pour soutenir la
croissance
et quand on sait qu'en plus ces
investissements publics sont par
ailleurs comptabilisé uniquement par
eurostat comme dépenses dans notre dette
n'est jamais en termes de patrimoine
d'amortissement je ne vois pas très bien
comment est ce que on va pouvoir avancer
sur ce sujet et c'est vraiment ça que je
suis ce qu'on parle beaucoup de la
france et des règles moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est quand même comment
est-ce qu'on va soutenir etc relancer
cette croissance et comment est-ce qu'on
va soutenir l'économie réelle je pense
que c'est vraiment ça dont on a besoin
merci en effet monsieur boyer je crois
que c'est ça l'essentiel c'est comment
dans les cinq ans qui viennent nous
relevons le défi que j'ai caractérisée
comme étant le conjuré la menace du
déclin de notre économie qui menace et
qui touche nos populations
je veux le dire ici d'ailleurs meilleur
un peu grave et si dans les cinq ans qui
viennent
n'inversons pas le cours des choses je
pense que c'est le projet européen lui
même qui est menacée et quand je parlais
d'europe de la dernière chance je pense
que cette commission est aussi un peu la
commission la dernière chance et ce
parlement est comme issus des parlements
la dernière chance ensemble ils vont
travailler dans le même sens ce qui est
plus de croissance plus d'emploi plus de
justice plus de progrès social non et ça
passe par cette notion absolument
cardinal qui en effet l'investissement
l'investissement c'est ce qui prépare
l'avenir
quand un continent n'investit plus une
prépare pas suffisamment son futur os il
y à bien ce qu'on appelle investment
gars
voilà cepedant c'est à dire le fait que
l'investissement aujourd'hui 17 %
inférieur à ce qu'il était avant la
crise c'est pas acceptable
et dans cette mesure là le plan
d'investissement ne proposait pas
chanter d'une caire est absolument
indispensable
il représente 300 milliards d'euros sur
trois ans et il ya ces deux principes
qui vont être observés d'abord il doit
être ciblée sur les secteurs qui sont
créateurs d'emplois
ensuite il faut que les choses soient
rapides c'est-à-dire que l'on peut pas
attendre 2017 donc ça se met en place
si dans les trois mois que la commission
est là nous allons y travailler qui a
quitté calais notamment la prendre ses
décisions et faire ses propositions et
puis troisièmement il faut qu'un
équilibre entre l'investissement privé
et l'investissement public je dirais
investissement privé autant que possible
et investissements publics quand c'est
nécessaire
et pour ça il faut aussi qu'on travaille
sur les outils financiers nous avons
notamment un outil formidable à notre
disposition qui s'appelle la banque
européenne d'investissement nous avons
augmenté son capital
ça lui a permis d'augmenter de 50% sa
capacité de prêt il faut sans doute
aller encore plus loin et trop secours à
la fois de nos petites et moyennes
entreprises et des dépenses
infrastructures indispensables pour le
continent mais l'investissement c'est la
batterie tout c'est essentiel au même
titre que le reste croissance
consolidation budgétaire il faut km ont
enfin pu je vous remercie monsieur
darius eurostat pour le thunder merci
monsieur le commissaire désigné le
gouvernement français vient d'annoncer
que la france n'avait pas l'intention de
réduire son déficit avant 2017
j'ai deux questions faire ce que ce ne
soit géré le premier à donner votre avis
bon je comprends que vous soyez pas
encore désigné de jeu quel est votre
avis si l'on accorde un traitement
particulier à la france en vertu de self
soi-disant circonstances particulières
et quels sont ces séquences
particulières le cas échéant deuxième
question
ce laxisme budgétaire est il dû
uniquement au rêve de flexibilité ou
plutôt au la mauvaise application des
règles mars king chairman et bien sûr le
président je demande l'avis du
commissaire désigné mais étant donné que
la france peut se retrouver dans une
situation de violation des règles je les
dis je suis venu ici avec la volonté de
répondre à toutes les questions quelle
qu'elle soit et donc celle ci ne me gêne
pas qu'une fois ni pour le passé ni pour
le futur je suis venu je crois avec une
sincérité bonne foi que vous l'entendez
depuis que je suis ici je suis pas là
pour être l'avocat d'un pays je ne suis
plus soumises les calmer des finances
suis pas là non plus pour être heureux
son procureur songez et des faits là
pour être commissaire européen pour
faire appliquer des règles qui
s'appliquent à tous à tous nous sommes
28 pays dans l'union européenne et la
france dont les appliquer comme tous
c'est pas y'a pas de grands payer de
petits pays dans l'europe il n'y a pas
de d'anciens payer nouveaux pays dans
l'europe il n'y a pas des pays
privilégiés des pays qui ne sont pas
dans l'europe et je le répète ma grosse
tête puisque vous une interdiction
la france n'a pas violé les règles tout
ce qui a été fait l'a été dans le cadre
des règles tout ce qui a été fait l'a
été avec l'accord de la commission
européenne
c'est un fait cette un fait mais ça va
pas vous dire le contraire
je reviens à la question monsieur
rosetti pour lui dire deux choses
d'abord sur les circonstances
exceptionnelles les circonstances
exceptionnelles elles sont prévues par
les textes suppose qu'il est une
récession sévère non pas dans un pays
mais dans l'ensemble la zone euro et
c'est au regard de ça qu'il faut
examiner ciel s'applique
je n'ai pas aujourd'hui les éléments je
le répète je ne suis pas commissaires en
charge mais ne sommes pas nous semble
utile dans cette situation là dans la
zone euro et donc encore une fois ce
sont toujours nos règles qui doivent
prévaloir est absolument dans l'aude et
donc il est hors de question qu'il y ait
un accès j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
mon introduction que je voulais
agir sans excès de complaisance pour les
uns sensibilité excessive pour les
autres ça vaut pour tous les pays dans
un sens comme dans l'autre soir très
exactement règles de conduite thomas
comme commissaire chargé des affaires
économiques et financières
fuck you enfin merci beaucoup fabio des
mazilles de la gouache nationaux si je
suis toujours impressionné de la façon
dont mes collègues mais je ne se laisse
pas impressionner n'a pas votre
expérience nous savons que les pays qui
ont fait le plus humide économie qui ont
dû et parler le plus sont ceux qui ont
la dette la plus élevée et je suis
impressionné par le fait que mes
collègues eux ne sont pas du tout
impressionnée par la réalité
moi je suis pour des finances solides
des états et c'est pourquoi j'aimerais
vous poser la question suivante lui une
enquête a été lancée contre l'irlande et
le luxembourg
à propos d'apple et d'autres il s'agit
de concurrence fiscale déloyale
est-ce que vous allez quand on tue
mouches que même si un candidat
conservateur et président actuel a
exercé des responsabilités au luxembourg
est ce que vous allez indépendamment de
cela soutenir la procédure en cours même
contre la volonté de monsieur kalt et
puis j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
pensez du fait que les tasses bancaire
dans certains pays devrait pouvoir être
soustraite à l'import ou déduites des
impôts
vous évoquez un point qu'on ne doit pas
parler jusqu'à présent qui est le fait
que je suis non seulement commissaires
désignés aux affaires économiques et
financières mais aussi la fiscalité à
l'union douanière et je voulais me tenir
en souriant que c'est quelque chose qui
m'a surpris mais je trouve très cohérent
pourquoi est-ce que ça m'a surpris parce
que comme tous les commissaires j'ai été
amené à rencontrer jean claude juncker
qui formaient sa commission il m'a dit
tu seras commissaire chargé des affaires
économiques et financières
ce n'est pas juste sorti de son bureau
je n'ai pas dit mais il ya une chose
qu'il ne m'avait pas dit tu le sais que
je serai commissaire à la fiscalité et à
l'union douanière images et vous que je
les ai découverts dans la conférence de
presse du président et pourquoi ça veut
dire que il me fait confiance pour ça
nous ne sommes pas de la même
nationalité
nous ne sommes pas du même parti il
luxembourgeois je suis français
l'origine et j'agirai l'art avec sa
pleine confiance et en totale
indépendance comme un commissaire et
c'est ça et ça extrêmement cohérent
parce que dans les discussions
auxquelles j'ai participé par exemple
dans le cas du g20 sur ces questions
fiscales qui sont délicates sur les
matière de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale qui sont essentiels contre
l'érosion des bases fiscales qui est
vital pour la mise en oeuvre de
l'échangé automatique d'informations et
une cohérence étroite entre les
questions économiques financières et
fiscales et c'est tout à fait cohérent
que ce portefeuille soit rassemblée hier
ils étaient séparés alors à partir de ça
il est des sujets qu'il faudra examiner
de manière très attentive
je pense notamment à tout ce qui
concerne la fiscalité du numérique
c'est un vrai sujet et il faudra agir
avec décider de son vote il simple que
c'est à l'endroit où se forme le profit
que de se faire la taxation
ça c'est un principe de base qui devra
bien sûr s'appliquer à nos propres
règles
j'agirai avec encore une fois en matière
fiscale
aussi nos règne il s'agit pas d'accorder
des dérogations à quiconque ne s'agit de
faire appliquer en toute matière mais
cette matière fiscale est une matière
passionnante et je le dis au passage ce
que je suis ici devant le parlement
européen
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous sommes
trop paralysé par les règle de
l'unanimité et il faudra peut-être c'est
le chant d'ailleurs du succès que
j'espère de la taxe sur les transactions
financières n'ont pas généraliser mais
étendre le principe des coopérations
renforcées
mais c'est un sujet qui me passionnait
dans lequel je m'investirai profondément
l'esprit de justice sociale et fiscale
qui doit caractériser tokyo placée
moriscot cateau pour les pères dire que
je suis arrivé s'il veut voir la nature
on voit que le ppe a taclé politique
économique française avec un commissaire
désignée je la faisais la même chose
lorsque j'ai eu hier
j'aimerais maintenant parler de la taxe
sur les transactions financières la
terre je tiens à vous féliciter parce
que vous avez adopté très rapidement une
taxe sur les transactions financières
cela permet au secteur financier de
contribuer au bien commun plutôt que de
se concentrer uniquement sur bénéficient
néanmoins une taxe est uniquement si et
puis qu'est-ce que son champ
d'application donc là s'était spécialisé
les limites et principalement en actions
il est essentiel qu'une cff couvre
suffit européenne comme suffisamment
d'actifs et génère suffisamment de
recettes pour avoir un impact sur les
problèmes que nous nous sommes contre
donc j'aimerais vous demander de nous
rassurer savez d'accord des pays
participants la coopération française
ressemblera plus ce qui est des
consultants la commission que ce qui
était console dans la france est ce que
vous partagez toujours l'idée qu'une
partie des recettes doivent être
utilisés pour la lutte contre la
pauvreté le changement climatique
en dehors de l'union européenne et quid
des pays participants remercient
si madame en effet je suis là pour
répondre à toutes les questions je suis
heureux quand il ya des questions qui
portent sur votre chose qu'un pays ou
qui me restera toujours très cher mais
aujourd'hui je vais examiner comme un
commissaire européen avec les lunettes
du commissaire robert avec les règles du
commissaire européen et avec cet esprit
là uniquement comme pour tous mes
collègues après tout parce qu'on ne peut
faire le procès a personne ici de sa
nationalité nous sommes des européens
sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières c'est un sujet auquel en
effet je me suis attaché comme liste de
l'économie et des finances dans mon pays
j'étais rappeler dans quelles
circonstances mais aussi dans le cadre
européen
la commission européenne avait fait une
proposition qui n'a pas pu aboutir dans
le cadre communautaire et à partir de ce
moment là onze pays ont lancé une
coopération renforcée à l'initiative de
cette coopération renforcée il y avait
notamment gelé rappeler une lettre que
j'ai signé avec mon ancien collègue et
toujours ami volga de sheikh le ministre
de l'économie et des finances cela
implique fédérale d'allemagne
je suis attaché au succès de cette
coopération renforcée pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que cette taxe va
contribuer à faire en sorte que le
secteur financier apporte sa juste part
ça contrecarre aussi certaines activités
comme le trading à haute fréquence qui
ne sont pas des activités qui sont
utiles et en face ça contribue je vous
le redis haut à financer la lutte contre
la pauvreté et le changement climatique
et puis ça donne un exemple c'est dire
que si nous sommes capables d'aboutir
sur cette coopération renforcée
peut-être n'aurait-il d'autres qui
permettront de débloquer un certain
nombre de sujets qui sont pendants pour
l'union européenne je vous redis ici que
j'apporterai le soutien technique de la
commission qui est pas au premier plan
et politiques pour que cette taxe puisse
aboutir
et je dis aussi ce qui a toujours été ma
position également commises et commis
les finances français il m'est arrivé de
penser à certains intérêts français
mais qu' il faut que certains dérivés au
moins soient taxés cette absolument
vital donc j'aurai une vision proactive
et ambitieuse de cet axe que je souhaite
voir aboutir si possible sous la
présidence italienne
ce sera un exemple 20 kg ou merci
beaucoup pour la commission in tatiana
béguines merci monsieur le commissaire
l'union douanière représente un pilier
fondamental de la politique commerciale
de l'union et l'ama les procédures
d'importation et d'exportation
harmoniser sont d'une importance vitale
pour l'union européenne et la
compétitivité de ses entreprises en
particulier les pme
en dépit des tentatives de modernisation
de l'année des normes douanière
l'absence d'uniformité en matière
d'applications constituer un obstacle
important et ne permet pas d'assurer
l'égalité entre les opérateurs
économiques de l'union quelles mesures
concrètes
avez vous l'intention de prendre pour
assurer une application cohérence des
normes communes et des procédures
fondamentales comme les contrôles
douaniers aux frontières extérieures de
l'union
et pour mettre fin au forum shopping en
matière de douane merci merci de cette
question je veux dire que je
travaillerai aussi en liaison étroite
avec votre commission sur cette partie
de mon portefeuille une ordinaire qui
est une partie très substantiel une
aumônière c'est un succès historique
pour l'union européenne je veux saluer
les 123 mille douaniers j'ai été misés
commis des finances le net plusieurs
dizaines de milliers en france je
connais leur travail qui est extrêmement
important il s'était fait fondamental et
non douanières nous représentons 15 % du
commerce mondial
nous avons dix mille kilomètres de
frontières extérieure
nous sommes au coeur de 12 150
engagements internationaux et donc c'est
pas une partie mineure des portefeuilles
kim est attribué elle évitable
elle est essentielle et c'est un succès
que les bons conforté par ce que et un
sens politique derrière tout ça c'est
que nos concitoyens attendent de la
protection ils ont le sentiment parfois
d'être soumis à une déferlante
commerciale d'être abreuvé de produits
contrefaits ce qui n'est pas rendre
hommage
on travaille les services des douanes et
à partir de ce moment là ma tâche
essentielle parmi vous avec vous ce sera
de passer du code douanier communautaire
datant de 2008
ah ah ah kow douaniers plus ambitieux
qui soit sur une union au 1er mai 2016
et avec les notions que vous avez
évoquées au coeur je vais pas entrer ici
dans le détail des règles de la
communauté au logis mais la commission
va respecter pleinement les règles en
vigueur pour permettre au parlement
européen et à ces commissions ne se
prononcer sur les actes pertinents ils
seront nombreux
c'est donc ensemble que nous allons
travailler à améliorer encore la
protection douanière à soutenir les
douaniers je pense aussi qu'il faudra
que nous mettions en place des outils
informatique commun pour permettre aux
douanes européennes et travailler de
manière plus rapide et plus efficace
mais cette tâche-là cette page de
protection contre des dégâts ressenti de
la mondialisation
elle sera tout à fait importante dans
mon portefeuille et je la mènerai avec
le parlement et ses commissions
étroitement fuck you
non je vous remercie madame analyse dote
pour le groupe s&d féliciter et merci
pour ce que vous avez dit sur le sujet
était la justice jusqu'à la machine est
la commission
quand vous le savez a déclaré que la
fraude fiscale l'évasion fiscale coûte
album jusqu'à 1 trillion d'euros
c'est là une somme énorme qui ne
bénéficient pas aux services publics
c'est également une concurrence déloyale
pour la plupart des entreprises qui
travaillent en fonction des règles
ed wood donc d'accord pour réduire cette
évasion fiscale oxfam christiane head et
d'autres ont indiqué que toutes les
multinationales
devrait présenter leurs comptes pays par
pays exactement comme les banques sont
censés le faire actuellement
enfin pouvez vous envisager des mesures
supplémentaires tels que liste noire
européenne des paradis fiscaux ainsi que
la situation des banques et leur
révocation lorsqu'elle participe à
certaines activités
madame des enfants du squat
merci pour cette question madame woerth
cela me donne l'occasion de vous
indiquer à quel point la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale l'évasion fiscale ou le
déplacement de bénéfices est important
pour moi en tant que ministre des
finances j'ai été impliqué sur cette
question surtout dans le cadre du g20
que nous avons travaillé pour lancer
l'initiative peps et là aussi l'europe
et est en première ligne
je vais également soutenir l'échangé
automatique d'informations en tant que
norme mondiale mais j'ai le sentiment
que nous européens nous devons faire
figure d'exemple en tant que ministre
j'ai également signé l'accord funk avec
les états unis et la les états unis ont
joué un rôle important dans ce combat je
jouerai engagement personnel profond je
pense que là aussi c'est quelque chose
qui est absolument terrible pour nos
économies 20 fraude fiscale cela réduit
la capacité de réduction des déficits
et je dirais que moralement c'est tout à
fait inacceptable impôts et là où il n'y
a pas suffisamment de règles on voit ce
qui se passe
il ya des échanges transfrontaliers qui
sont favorisés et sein de remettre le
cadeau
nous devons travailler contre la fraude
pour lutter contre la fraude au niveau
international mais également au sein de
l'union européenne
iti je pense ici à la tva il faut
renforcer notre ami
est également là dessus mes premières
décisions sont prises je vais sans aucun
doute les renforcer et tenter devrait
tout fait pour qu'elle rentre il faut
qu'elles soient mises en oeuvre alors
vous m'avez également posé une question
sur les paradis fiscaux
j'ai pas de vous donner de réponse
définitive parce qu'il faut encore
travailler ses locations mais je peux
vous rappeler une expérience j'ai eu en
tant que ministre des finances lorsque
j'ai présenté une législation sur le
système bancaire qui visait à dire que
toutes les banques doivent déclarer
leurs activités sur dans les paradis
fiscaux alors vous savez parfois on
présente la france comme un pays qui
n'est pas vraiment un exemple mais je
pense qu'il ya de bonnes choses qui ont
été faites dans mon pays onkyo ludek
merci vous n'êtes ni la manière du ppe
dont mister showman
merci monsieur le président je me suis
le commissaire désigné je ne vais pas
parler de france mais d'europe
excusez moi mais les économies ne sont
pas en bonne santé et certains pays sont
confrontés à de graves problèmes de
durabilité
et puis il ya des menaces de sécurité
qui pèse sur l'europe et qui sape la
confiance monsieur moscovici vous avez
beaucoup parlé de croissance de
stabilité sociale
mais ça ne sont pas les seules choses
qui comptent je voudrais votre avis
personnel il y à des pays qui vont avoir
des problèmes de financement vous pensez
que c'est improbable
et puis j'aimerais avoir aussi votre
avis quelles sont les mesures que les
pays devraient prendre pour réduire ce
risque grave et enfin si vous êtes
confirmé
comment allez vous motiver inspiré ou
forcer les ministres des finances des
états membres à entreprendre de telles
réformes voix
mme aubry mis aux fourneaux asking alors
je ne vous blâme pas de ne pas avoir
posé de questions sur la france
au contraire je vous en remercie vous
avez posé une question importante
comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
cela fait longtemps que je pense que la
dette publique et privée
c'est un danger pour l'économie et pour
les services publics lorsque j'ai
commencé dans les années 80 et 89 comme
jeune fonctionnaire
le budget de l'éducation est devenu le
premier budget avant même celui de la
défense
moi je préfère que ce soit l'éducation
qu'ils soient financés les hôpitaux tout
ce qui est bon pour les gens pour la
compétitivité
c'est pourquoi cette combat contre
l'endettement est un combat que je
mènerai avec beaucoup de fermeté
parce que je suis convaincu que la dette
n'est pas productive alors est-ce que je
craint maintenant des problèmes
d'endettement à nouveau écoutez je pense
qu'au cours des années passées
beaucoup a été fait pour assurer la
stabilité de l'eurozone et des progrès
ont été faits par un grand nombre de
pays
la commission ayant joué son rôle nous
avons essayé aussi de rompre le cercle
vicieux
est ce que les cartes et l'écart entre
la dette publique et la vie privée mais
nous sommes tous confrontés à un
problème de dette publique
c'est pourquoi une partie importante de
notre politique économique et en
particulier nos règles portent sur la
nécessité de cette réduction je serai
très attentif à toutes menaces
éventuelles qui pourraient resurgir
effectivement c'est vrai que les choses
s'améliorent mais en tant que
commissaire jeu devrait convaincre et
agir de façon à ce que mes collègues
les ministres des finances dans le cadre
de l'eurogroupe et de l'ecofin soit très
prudent en la matière avec you
merci marc meneau pour les non inscrits
oui monsieur moscovici il est très clair
maintenant d'après votre réponse
précédente que vous êtes prêts à mettre
la france sous tutelle aux ors de la
commission européenne et de l'euro
si si par ailleurs je m'interroge sur la
pertinence de l'architecturé de la
commission et sur la concurrence entre
les commissaires qui meurent ap
il me rappelle étrangement
l'organisation de bercy sous votre
ministère et mènera et la soummam
résultat la cacophonie
vous serez inaudible l'analyse de
l'échec qu'actualisé de votre mission
commune de l'économie et des finances en
france tient notamment la dispersion des
portefeuilles puisque vous aviez sept
ministres en charge des affaires
économiques
vos collègues cahuzac montebourg ont
tenu les devants de la scène et votre
autorité n'a jamais été affirmé or votre
portefeuille est à la fois dépossédé des
questions de l'euro des marchés
financiers et en plus vous êtes cornaqué
par un vice-président chargé de la
croissance économique de
l'investissement est également dans la
compétitivité dans cette organisation
matricielle au la responsabilité est
éclatée qui va faire quoi
est il vrai que toutes vos initiatives
de ventre est approuvé préalablement par
le vice-président à l'euro monsieur
dombrowski la confusion des rôles est
telle que même le président de la
commission econ a dû écrire monsieur
juncker pour lui demander de préciser
qui fera quoi je m'avoue soucier cette
question-là ajouté je suis avec une
résine à galles à gaz la solution sera
monsieur parce qu'elle la mer c'est à
dire
simoneau je ne reviens pas sur la france
une fois plus que je pense que le mot
tutelle n'existe pas dans le vocabulaire
repères ni dans l'esprit européen plus
comprenais pas ça les règles ne prévoit
pas de tutelle
il s'agit absolument pas de ce genre de
choses mais je réponds à votre autre
question qui est une question je crois
important sur l'organisation la
commission me présente locale a choisi
une nouvelle organisation qui est un
défi pour nous tous nous allons relever
ensemble
il a choisi d'organiser la commission
autrement qui le délégué une partie de
ses pouvoirs à un groupe de vice
président moi j'ai un portefeuille large
qui couvre deux directions générales et
je vais contribuer aux travaux de six
des sept vis
résidant dans leurs tâches de
coordination ce n'est pas là encore une
tutelle
c'est une chance de contribuer aux
priorités de cette commission
c'est une marque de confiance du
président jonckheere ça nous oblige à
travailler ensemble c'est que ça peut
paraître étrange et à certains mais ça
s'appelle la collégialité tout
simplement
alors concrètement les réponses ont en
effet donné par le président au caire
les directions générales ecofin est
accusations 2 elles sont souvent
autonome autorités mais les vice
présidents peuvent demander des notes en
concertation avec moi et c'est le rôle
notamment lorsqu'il représente le
président deuxièmement salissant de
l'ordre du jour du collège
il faut un accord du vice présidente
concernés ces départs veto un blocage
elle pense qu'il faut quand même changé
nos catégories mentales c'est la
question de la collégialité et de la
qualité nos travaux il y a de la
confiance nécessaire il y en a entre
lire ticket panel valdis dombrovskis et
ses moi pourquoi ne passerions l'otan
dans des conflits bureaucratique inutile
et puis troisièmement et la question la
représentation externe zone euro va
parler avec mes collègues des temples
inkala déjà indiqué que je représenterai
la commission alors groupe dans sa
conférence de presse
pour le reste faut laisser à la
commission et à son président à capacité
de s'organiser
c'est la lettre et l'esprit des traités
mais je vais vous dire une chose je suis
tout à fait tranquille avec ça j'ai
confiance dans cette organisation
je jouerai le jeu et notamment avec
diakité tanel valdis dombrovskis
nous avons l'intention ferme qui est
d'être une équipe économique au service
de l'europe thank you merci giorgos
christophe je vous remercie monsieur le
président bon je ne poserais pas de
questions sur
dj excédentaires et les déficits
après tout je viens de grèce monsieur le
commissaire désigné
j'ai lu vos réponses écrites et j'en ai
conclu que vous êtes en faveur de
solutions pour encourager les
gouvernements des états membres à
promouvoir des changements structurels
nécessaires bien que difficile
pouvez-vous élaboré sur cette question
cela me paraît intéressant car cela
pourrait réduire les cours qui sont
souvent associées à des changements
structurels délicat les gouvernements en
france en italie en grèce et ailleurs
pourrait acier devenir plus dynamique et
avoir une approche plus efficace
merci beaucoup monsieur monsieur
christophe poussette
cette question je me lie à dire une
chose au passage c'est que je les dis
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps que
commises et comme il finance a travaillé
dans le cadre de l'eurogroupe sur la
situation des pays sous programme j'ai
l'occasion devient trois fois dans votre
pays la dernière fois c'était un petit
mois où j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
le premier ministre monsieur samaras
commises l'économie et des finances je
me suis battu l époque c'était une
guerre le président de l'eurogroupe pour
qu'un on préserve l'intégrité de zone
euro et pour que la grèce reste dans la
zone rouge
je pense que c'était une bonne décision
je m'en réjouis et j'ai mené ce combat
avec beaucoup d'activités pas voter
j'étais d'ailleurs dès le 14 septembre
2012 dans votre pays
après avoir rencontré le premier
ministre avec le président la république
à la fin juin et une même première
visite comme commissaires parce que les
utilités internationaux portant se fera
en grâce est aussi un chiffre pour
témoigner de notre solidarité et pour
travailler avec les autorités de ces
deux pays
à quoi à la relance de la croissance et
là vous poser une autre question qui et
comment concilier croissance et la force
structurelle pour moi n'y a pas
d'opposition
les réformes structurelles sont pas les
réformes qui sont là pour faire mal si
on de la forme qu'ils sont là pour
augmenter le potentiel de compétitivité
de l'économie pour lui permettre
investir davantage elles doivent
concerner tout ce qu'on sait c'est à
dire à la fois le marché du travail mais
aussi la qualité des infrastructures la
formation professionnelle le système de
logement
il s'agit pas pour la commission d'être
dans tous les détails mais il s'agit
effectivement de faire en sorte que nos
économies en fonction leur situation
qu'elles ne sont pas toutes les mêmes
bien sûr et les pays qui ont une avance
sur d'autres et d'autres qui ont un
retard à combler ou qui ont les efforts
supplémentaires à faire
eh bien nous fassions ses réformes
pourquoi faire avoir une économie plus
réactive et les commis plus créatives
par une icône et plus forte par une
inconnue qui soit capable de créer plus
d'emplois qui se tait pas d'investir
davantage et ça la commission a là un
rôle à jouer un rôle moteur
les états mans conserve le rôle
essentiel sans tutelle encore une fois
mais avec une volonté d'aller dans ce
sens très précis et je serai un
commissaire réformiste 5 euros merci à
présent pour la commission imco madame
marlène mizzi un merci monsieur le
président j'aime pas me concentrer sur
ce qui s'est passé ou pas en france dans
le passé mais j'aimerais me concentrer
sur ce que nous aimerions voir à
l'avenir pour l'union européenne au
cours du dernier mandat le parlement a
réussi à adopter le code des douanes
moderniser l'objectif principal d'aller
vers un système de douanes européennes
électronique la non conformité et les
produits non conformes passe à travers
la douane ce qui cause des dégâts pour
les
citoyens et une concurrence déloyale
vis-à-vis des entreprises qui respectent
les normes environnementales sociales
notamment
êtes vous prêts à avoir une action plus
coordonnée une coopération plus
coordonnée avec d'autres les autorités
de surveillance des marchés pour
garantir la sécurité des produits et
pour éviter le dumping à partir de
produits non conformes qu'allez vous
faire pour garantir une bonne mise en
oeuvre des dpi pour voir des actions
concrètes contre les produits
contrefaits et parce que il ya des
pertes de 100 millions d'euros et une
perte de recettes
et puis enfin quelles sont les étapes
concret ce que vous allez adopter pour
assurer une application cohérente du
code des douanes et comment allez-vous
avoir une définition et puis fin de
l'intervention malheureusement hors
micro merci merci madame
écoutez je le redis l'union douanière la
douane c'est une partie qui te fait
intégrante et importante du portefeuille
et la tâche essentielle du commissaire
chargé d'une aumônière ce sera avec vous
de mettre en place ce nouveau code qui
sera le coq de l'union ici à 2016 et lui
nous aurons à travailler sur un très
grand nombre d'actes délégué vous avez
souligné au passage la nécessité de
mettre en place des outils des outils
informatiques qui soit commun pour quoi
faire pour permettre aux douanes tout
simplement d'agir de manière plus
efficace
mais vous avez souligné aussi d'autres
points qui sont tout à fait importante
pour moi qui ait la nécessité
d'améliorer la coopération entre les
douanes et d'autres nous autorités
notamment les autorités de marché parce
que il ya là une interaction qui est
tout à fait évidente il y à plus de 60
législatif pour lesquels les douanes
sont requis afin
d'améliorer les situations liées à des
échanges wall des mouvements
transfrontières et c'est pour ça qu'il
faudra qu'on travaille notamment au
développement de ce qu'on appelle un
symbole window on pour faciliter le flux
d'informations entre les différentes
autorités appliquent et donc il faudra
qu'on travaille aussi avec les autorités
du marché intérieur pour une tête avec
l'air vous m'avez aussi interrogé sur le
principe du pays d'origine
vous faites référence là des règles non
préférentiel d'origine applicable et des
importations dans cette mesure là je
veillerai en n'appliquant la nouvelle
législation douanière à la possibilité
d'inclure il lisse extensive de produits
avec des règles spécifiques
d'interprétation du principe qu'on
appelle la sultane show tranchant mais
nous aurons l'occasion de travailler sur
tout ça ma volonté c'est vraiment avec
le parlement européen d'avancés d'un
code des douanes ambitieux et
intelligent
enfin que nantes est ce ma vie merci
monsieur mariage merci monsieur le
commissaire désigné le parlement
européen
dans le cas dans une résolution en date
de mars 2014 estimé que la politique de
la troïka en irlande au portugal en
grèce et en chiffres arrêtés une
catastrophe
monsieur moscovici la troïka a fait de
la grèce ainsi le tiers nous pays est
devenu empli de chômeurs et le pauvre
une crise humanitaire terrible a été
déclenchée la responsabilité est pour
nous elle aime bien de l'eurogroupe et
en tant que ministre français vous en
étiez mans vous allez même joué un rôle
déterminant nous ma question êtes vous
satisfaire des résultats désastreux
entraînée par la politique de la troïka
en grèce et son nom en tant que
commissaire allez vous faire pour
indemniser la grèce
simple pourquoi la troïka indemnise la
grèce et pour que l' on remédie à la
dette
si vous pensez que cette politique a été
erroné pourquoi n'avez vous pas ce
procédé à un exercice d'autocritique à
quoi devrions-nous vous donner la
possibilité de continuer à détruire la
vie des européens en tant que
commissaire cette fois monsieur le
député je respecte vos convictions nous
les partageons pas à l'évidence
moi j'ai commise l'économie et des
finances il semble leur gros puis et
puis avant un débat d'ailleurs j'ai été
persuadé d'emblée qu'il était
fondamental de préserver l'intégrité de
la zone euro et que la grèce qui est un
grand pays qui est liée plus que
d'autres l'histoire de la démocratie
européenne continue appartenir à la zone
euro
et j'ai passé avec mes collègues
incertain au bout d'une nuit va faire en
sorte que les programmes soient financés
c'est vrai que je connais la colère qui
existe en brèche le dis j'ai été trois
fois on veut payer à la fois encore il
ya un mois je sais qu'il ya besoin je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure à monsieur legal
d'infléchir la façon dont fonctionne
notre cas sans doute je sais aussi que
nous devons être parfois moins intrusif
dans la manière dont nous définissions
les réformes mais en même temps je pense
que c'est la forme était nécessaire
nécessaire à la grèce nécessaire à
l'europe nécessaire à l'économie grecque
ça c'est ma conviction très profonde et
donc je ne suis pas vous comprenez dans
l'attitude de quelqu'un qui vient en
pénitents flagellant en promettant je ne
sais quels dédommagements
je pense en revanche qu'il faut être
plus attentif que nous n'avons été
jusqu'à présent on sort des populations
à la manière dont ces réformes se
traduise socialement et là dessus
présent au caire s'est dit à quel point
il était important pour lui qui est
cette dimension sociale prise en compte
dans la manière dont
réformes sont conduites notamment dans
les pays sous programme et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je le redis ici
étant très attentif à ces questions
denny fuyant aucune forme de dialogue
les premiers déplacements
sinon le premier sera pour la grèce à
nouveau pour examiner la façon dont nos
programmes chez met en place et quelles
améliorations nous pouvons apporter mais
oui une option fondamentale
je lui dis je le redis je n'assume sait
bien que la grèce soit dans la zone euro
et je m'en réjouis
fuck you je vous remercie
c'est le tireur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le commissaire
désigné la dette explose alors je ne
veux pas entrer dans la discussion où le
conflit qui porte sur la mise en oeuvre
des recommandations spécifiques pays et
savoir si ça vous qualifie en tant que
commissaire mais est ce que là ça fait
partie de votre portefeuille
cette recommandation spécifique pays et
puis vous avez dit ce que devait faire
katainen et dombrowski mais
pourriez-vous clarifier notre rôle
seriez vous d'accord pour dire que
monsieur juncker et le boss très grands
joueurs ce qui c'est mais cet endroit ce
qui c'est votre boss une troisième
question vous avez souligné la
coopération collective agir en tant que
collège dans la commission dans la
presse française vous avez donné
l'impression que vous alliez vouloir
ébranlé la commission est ce que c'est
pas un peu schizophrène j'ai commencé
peut-être pas par ce dernier point parce
que j'entends parler de fusion de
schizophrénie
mais avant tout des histoires familiales
il se trouve que mon père est un
professeur de psychologie sociale est ma
mère était psychanalyste mais pour ce
qui concerne le sens psychologiquement
tout à fait stable et donc absolument
pas dans une situation de schizophrénie
le paranoïaque de tout ce que vous
voulez je pense avoir un équilibre qui
est basé sur des convictions sur une
expérience sur un tempérament et sur une
volonté de dialogue avec tous et c'est
comme ça que j'agirais pour le reste oui
les camps prises spécifiques comme des
jeunes sont évidemment d'un portefeuille
nouveau travailler à faire en sorte que
leur application soit plus efficace car
jusqu'à présent le taux d'application
des conduits spécialement des choses est
évidemment beaucoup trop faible sur le
dernier point ce jeu peut être m'y
attendais un peu davantage l'histoire de
bosse en bosse il ya un président dans
la commission européenne et l'arôme
particulier qui est prévu par les
traités et lui il est l'autorité
personnelle
le président jonckheere a choisi dans
certains cas et dans certaines
situations de déléguer ses pouvoirs du
président et des vice-présidents et à
partie moment où ses vice-présidents ont
des pouvoirs délégués et dans l'exercice
de ses pouvoirs délégués
ils sont équivalents à ceux qu'elle
président que je travaillerai bien sûr
dans cet esprit là mais fondamentalement
fondamentalement et tout le monde le
sait ici parce que comme parlementaire
en par vous travaillez avec la
commission pour certains depuis
longtemps et avec plusieurs commissions
l'esprit de la commission c'est la
collégialité
ça n'est pas la supervision ce n'est pas
la tutelle ce n'est pas le chaperonnage
ce n'est pas les hiérarchies c'est
travailler ensemble est ce que nous
voulons faire avec valdis dombrovskis
c'est avec eux qu'il est à l'aise c'est
travailler ensemble hier encore j'étais
avec monsieur dombrowski ce dans tous
les aspects notre portefeuille pourquoi
parce que s'ils ne tirons pas dans le
même sens si nous passons notre temps à
savoir qui fait quoi pendant ce temps là
on travaille pas on n'avance pas et donc
non on attention à moi n'est pas
d'ébranler la commission c'est de la
renforcer et 10 m 1 ma force de travail
ma conviction toute mon énergie pour
quelque chose avance
avec les autres par contre nous wikio
merci au nom de la commission intat
pedro silva pereira
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
commissaire désigné au nom de la
commission in tard je voudrais vous
poser deux questions supplémentaires
comme cela a été décidé par les groupes
politiques de lindt à vous connaissez
l'importance qu'il ya là commerce
international équitable sur pour
l'agenda européen de la croissance
économique
alors quelles sont vos priorités et
quelles sont les initiatives que vous
voulez proposer sur la coopération
douanière internationale et la fixation
de normes mondiales sur les femmes en
particulier sur les facilitations
commercial et je voudrais savoir comment
vous avez l'intention avec les
principaux partenaires de l'union
d'évoquer les débats les défis liés
auxquels sont de douane la sauvegarde
des flux de génériques sécurité de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement et lutte
contre tout type de fraude ce qui est
capital pour les opérateurs économiques
de l'union merci hein tu veux le match
et merci beaucoup vous m'avez interrogé
sur la coopération bonnière
international qui est essentiel
effectivement pour l'union douanière
nous explose en tant qu'activité qui est
effectuée aux frontières extérieures de
l'union
les douanes ont une dimension
internationale intrinsèque et quand il
les importations d'un pays constituent
les exportations pour un autre l'union
coopère déjà avec des pays partenaires
au plan bilatéral et multilatéral en
particulier sur les questions de
sécurité et de protection des citoyens
en promouvant la facilitation
commerciale et en luttant contre les
marchandises qui enfreignent les dons
les lois nous avons des accords de
coopération avec nos principaux
partenaires commerciaux
mais nous avons aussi des accords aussi
sur la sécurité des chaînes
d'approvisionnement disposition ou
règles d'origine et facilitation
commerciale qui figure d'ailleurs dans
tous ses accords commerciaux et l'union
participe également à la fixation des
normes internationales dans le cadre de
l'organisation mondiale des douanes et
pendant mon mandat j'agirai
effectivement avec mon ma collègue ccja
main stream dans le cadre du collège
pour mettre l'accent en particulier sur
les relations douanière transatlantiques
et la coopération aux frontières de
l'est de l'union
et français un méditerranéenne et je
travaille là également à la coopération
douanière avec la chine
le type et ses aspects et douanier sera
également à mon programme et à mon ordre
du jour et je devrai travailler sur ce
dossier avec madame maelström c'est le
cas aussi dans le cadre de la
coopération avec la chine pour renforcer
les droits de propriété intellectuelle
je pense en particulier aussi aux
rapports avec l'ukraine et la russie
donc cet aspect de coopération
internationale est un élément clé de ce
travail que je serai dans ce domaine
la dame sir pathétik haydn à dieu merci
j'ai deux questions à vous poser comme
un savant équilibre économique chez les
recettes et les dépenses vous avait déjà
parlé de votre engagement pour vous
attaquer à la fraude et à l'évasion
fiscale
donc je ne m'attendais pas de vous que
vous répétiez tout ça mais la question
est la suivante est ce que vous êtes
prêt à vous engager sur le programme de
la commission actuelle en ce qui
concerne une meilleure fiscalité plus le
parlement a déjà amené quelques travaux
sur cette question et puis en ce qui
concerne l'économie numérique quelles
seraient vos stratégies pour développer
une bonne fiscalité et lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale en europe et puis un
deuxième question comment développer le
semestre européen et les sanctions et
les assiste les incitants qui existent
pour avoir des changements structurels
et de la croissance merci je trouve la
whip it again
merci tout d'abord je répète
guest ivg la lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale l'application de
l'initiative ppte
l'entrée en vigueur d'une norme mondiale
pour l'échangé automatique
d'informations tout cela ce sera une de
mes premières priorités en tant que
commissaire en charge de la fiscalité
c'est essentiel pour le citoyen c'est
une grande tâche politique de notre
union nous devons travailler sur cette
question avec toute notre énergie avec
toute notre force et je vais consacrer
une grande partie de mon énergie à sens
deuxièmement j'agirai sur la base de ce
qui a déjà été décidé par la commission
et sur la base de ce qui était proposé
par le parlement européen
le problème est là je parle des
questions de fiscalité le problème
disait je sais que nous sommes trop
souvent bloqué par la règle de
l'unanimité
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
important que la question le dossier
taxe sur les transactions financières
soit couronnée de succès parce que si on
peut montrer que les coopérations
renforcées peuvent être cornell de
succès on pourrait peut-être en avoir
d'autres tout aussi efficace en ce qui
concerne semestre européen et le lien
avec la fiscalité vous le savez la
fiscalité est en grande partie une
compétence nationale mais mais nous
devons également un vrai à
l'harmonisation
nous devons également tenter de
renforcer l'équité sociale et économique
de notre système est là le système
européen me semble-t-il pourrait
intégrer davantage ces questions de
fiscalité tout en respectant bien
évidemment le principe de subsidiarité
ce principe il nous tient à coeur à tous
les parlements nationaux s'en tiennent à
leur souveraineté en matière fiscale
mais je pense que l'union a un rôle
important à jouer
il faut renforcer la place de la
fiscalité dans le semestre européen
merci siegfried morrison ppe merci
comme nationale bergman monsieur le
commissaire désigné vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises que vous êtes ici en
tant que commissaire désigné pas en tant
qu'ancien ministre des finances français
mais nous promet sûr pas oublié votre
performant performance votre échec en
tant que ministre des finances avec une
augmentation du chômage de la dette
française une baisse de la compétitivité
avec des entreprises qui quitte la
france
nous ne voulons pas que cela arrive aux
populations européennes pendant que vous
serez en charge du portefeuille économie
alors je vous pose la question d'abord
la dette publique en france atteint les
95 % cette année selon un projet de
budget elle vous d'accord pour dire
qu'un niveau aussi élevé de dette
peut-être qui elle a été présentée
constitue un risque pour l'économie et
pour les emplois deuxième question
lorsque vous étiez ministre des finances
vous avez à plusieurs reprises présenté
des chiffres macroéconomiques trop
optimiste par exemple et perspectives de
croissance pour la france
est-ce que c'était là une erreur serait
beaucoup plus prudents à l'avenir en
tant que commissaire européen chargé des
affaires économiques
je vais répondre à cette question comme
commun toutes les autres qui ont été
posées sur sur le même thème en relisant
d'une part que comme isolé commis
défense il finance français j'ai été
attaché au sérieux budgétaire que j'ai
réduit les déficits le qu'aucune de mes
décisions étaient prises en
contravention des règles que toutes mes
décisions ont été prises en
l'approbation de la commission et du
conseil
tout absolument tout et je le répète et
en prévision est en exécution et donc si
vous voulez jules encore une fois je
suis là vous le voyez pour répondre à
toutes les questions pour accepte tous
les débats mais bon je suis là dessus
solide je pense qu'il faut à la fois se
garder d'être un avocat de la france je
ne me serais pas déçu garder aussi de
faire le procès de ce grand pays parce
que je le dis au passage quand même
la france a besoin de l'europe et moi je
suis là pour faire en sorte aussi que
les remises européenne s'applique en
france
mais l'europe a besoin de la france une
france forte chaque fois que je parlais
avec mon agent me désabonner le stand
france et ça c'est toujours bref c'est
toujours vrai et donc nous faisons pas
en sorte d'affaiblir non plus ce pays ce
qui ne signifie pas en quoi que ce soit
être indulgent ou manquer de crédibilité
alors après vous m'interrogez sur les
prévisions macroéconomiques les régions
d'accueil comiques comme il est connu
des finances j'ai proposé au parlement
qui l'a accepté à l'unanimité
gauche et droite la création d'une
instance qui s'appelle au conseil des
finances publiques qui est indépendant
qui est placé près de notre cour des
comptes et qui par ailleurs madame
gaulard en effet un être en dialogue
constant avec la dg est clean
et tout cela est l'application du six
pattes
certains voulaient une règle d'or nous
avons fait ce choix qui a été approuvé
par tous et cette institution au conseil
nous reprend sans aucune indulgence les
autorités françaises sur les prévisons
de croissance et de telle façon que nous
sommes plus dans la situation que nous
avons connue dans le passé ou des
gouvernements pouvaient faire et dire
n'importe quoi et tout cela est
soigneusement vérifiés et les règles
européennes s'applique déjà en france
thank you talking un groupe s&d mais
germaine merci monsieur le président
c'est clair les grands et les petits
pays doivent être traitées sur un pied
d'égalité les mêmes règles s'appliquent
à tous les pays doivent également pour
les entreprises qu'elles soient grandes
ou petites les possibilités d'évasion
fiscale sont plus importantes pour les
grandes entreprises
et j'ai une question spécifique d'avoir
des rapports par pays pour les
entreprises pour voir quelle est la
situation on voit que la situation
actuelle n'est pas juste et n'est pas
efficace
ce qui m'amène à une
deuxième question d'autres plus générale
nous réjouissons du fait que votre
portefeuille couvre la coordination
économique et la fiscalité
ça c'est une occasion à saisir la
politique fiscale c'est un élément
essentiel de la gêne d'heure pour la
croissance et l'emploi
mais comment garantir comment allez vous
garantir que la politique fiscale de
l'union européenne soit pleinement
intégré dans le semestre européen et
quelles sont les initiatives concrètes
que vous allez prendre dans ce domaine
merci on ne fusse bonnes choses en ce
qui concerne votre premier point mais
taille de l'entreprise luc lorsque l'on
regarde ce qu'ils réalisaient sous
l'égide du g20 et bien c'est justement
cela que ça parle
cette initiative pex la lutte contre le
déplacement de bénéfices la lutte contre
le feu l'intégration de l'économie
numérique dans le champ d'application
tout ce que tout cela cible c'est le
fait qu'il ya des activités
transfrontalières
du côté des d'énormes entreprises qui
évite tout contrôle
c'est sur cette question que travail le
g20 l'union européenne doit jouer un
rôle important sur ce dossier vous fait
une proposition je peux pas répondre
directement à cela on pourrait en parler
en tête à tête
je soumettrai cette idée mais dg mais
nous devons vraiment faire preuve de
prudence en ce qui concerne la fiscalité
et le semestre européen maintenant j'ai
déjà donné une première réponse il ya
quelques minutes je pense que la
fiscalité la fiscalité pardon c'est en
grande partie une question nationale
mais que au sein des législations
nationales
il y à des distorsions qui sont néfastes
à l'économie ainsi on taxe trop le
travail et pas suffisamment l'énergie
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que la commission devrait faire des
propositions visant à harmoniser ou en
tout cas évident a invité les
gouvernements nationaux à entreprendre
des efforts dans ce domaine c'est là
pour laquelle on devra discuter
davantage de fiscalité dans le semestre
avec le parlement avec votre commission
parlementaire je suis tout à fait
convaincu que c'est nécessaire je suis
tout à fait disposé à travailler dans ce
domaine avec vous avec votre commission
parlementaire avec le parlement afin de
renforcer la place que prend la
fiscalité dans le semestre européen
parce qu'il ne faut plus approche plus
globale et je pense qu'il était tout à
fait pertinent d'avoir un portefeuille
qui comprend l'économie les finances et
la fiscalité ces trois éléments sont
indissociables avec l'union d'honneur
également merci par patrick le hyaric
pour l'accueil sur le commissaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que le
crédit public puisse être un moyen pour
de sortir des difficultés actuelles
jusque là banque centrale
vous faites la création monétaire pour
les banques privées mais que ces banques
aujourd'hui n'irrite pas l'économie au
même taux est ce qu'il ne faut pas à
conditionner la création monétaire pour
les banques à l'efficacité économique et
sociale et d'autre part à partir d'un
outil qui existe c'est à dire l'article
123 du traité
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas envisager
la création en lien avec la banque
d'investissement et la banque centrale
d'un fonds européens certains disent une
sorte de trésor public qui servirait au
développement social au développement
humain et écologique qui pourrait
refinancer un certain nombre de dettes
d'état et distribuerait un crédit
sélectif en fonction de l'emploi créé de
l'investissement des services publics
européens qu'on pourrait développer et d
infrastructure européenne créatrice
d'emplois merci merci monsieur le hyaric
là encore il ya plusieurs questions
il pense en effet qu'il est très
important d'abord d'alimenter
correctement l'économie en liquidités
ensuite de lutter contre la
fragmentation financière
un calcul menacer la stabilité de nos
systèmes financiers et d'assurer que les
canaux de transition la politique
monétaire une transmission marche
jusqu'à la petite entreprise
il n'est pas normal qu'une entreprise se
financer à des taux différents selon
qu'elle est d'un côté ou de l'autre par
exemple de la frontière entre l'italie
et l'autriche
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai eu
comme commissaire évidemment je peux
très peu de commentaires sur l'action de
la banque centrale européenne on le
comprend mais globalement je pense que
la banque centrale européenne sous la
conduite de monsieur dry et à jouer un
rôle positif dans le sauvetage de la
zone euro prenant des mesures qui était
approprié de la même façon il était
fondamental qu'avance millions bancaires
et non bancaires qui permet de s'assurer
d'une part que les banques sont saines
qui permet aussi de s'assurer de
mécanismes de résolution en cas de
faillite qui soit plus positif
enfin il est indispensable de faire en
sorte en effet que le système bancaire
que le système financier servent
l'économie réelle et de ce point de vue
là nous avons à la fois des outils
publics et des outils privé les types
public c'est la banque européenne
d'investissement vrai que son bras armé
le fonds européen d'investissement dans
le cadre du programme d'investissement
de 300 milliards d'euros décidé par
jean-claude hiquet à l'évidence nous
devons nous appuyer là-dessus le pays
avec son augmentation de capital a déjà
augmenté sa capacité de 4 50% le fmi est
aussi plus actifs faut-il aller plus
loin et comment il sera une des
questions qui lui seront opposés à eric
hattan elle et moi même quand nous
allons examiner en liaison avec jonathan
il la façon dont ce plan sera mise en
oeuvre
il ya sans doute là des capacités
supérieures et pour l'investissement
privé et pour l'investissement public en
infrastructures et je ne regarde que
d'oublier
par ailleurs il ya le système bancaire
privé et tout doit être fait tout doit
être fait en effet pour que parce qu'il
est plus sûr parce qu'il est moins
fragmenté
parce qu'il est aussi mieux contrôler
les fonds bancaires ayvaz l'entreprise
parce que les sytèmes aucun ne
fonctionne pas en vase clos
c'est un système qui doit être au
service de le tenir elle davantage et ça
il nous reviendra des veillées
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre
l'audition de pierre moscovici devant le
parlement européen
tout de suite la suite de nos programmes
sur public sénat